[Musique]
cherche quoi bien sûr à utiliser les
micros qu'on va placer dans les couloirs
pour les questions dans la mesure où ces
retransmis est enregistrée merci
beaucoup merci de lui a réservé le
meilleur accueil
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
normalement vous devriez passer sans
encombre à travers ce que je vais vous
raconter ce matin d'abord parce que vous
rentrez de vacances et dont vous êtes
reposé vous avez passé des nuits normal
ensuite vous êtes jeune et vous
connaissez problème en cette définition
de la jeunesse qui est on est jeune
temps qu'on se croit éternelle est
invincible et donc tant qu'on est
éternel et invincible n'importe quel
problème dont on peut vous parler c'est
même pas peur donc normalement même pas
peur qui dans cette salle n'a jamais
entendu parler de transition énergétique
bon tout le monde a entendu parler de
transition énergétique qui si tout de
suite là je vous disais pas de
conférence il ya devoir sur table et je
vous demande de me définir d'énergie est
capable de répondre à la question
alors il ya trois courageux ou
inconscient
voilà ce que je vais essayer de vous
expliquer ce matin c'est que
transitionner sur un truc qu'on n'est
pas capable de définir c'est quand même
un peu problématique est donc ce que je
vais essayer de vous montrer ce matin
sait de quoi on parle quand on parle du
problème à traiter donc je ne vais pas
beaucoup vous parlez de solutions de
toute façon ça va vous occuper jusqu'à
votre mort donc c'est comme ça vous
aurez un peu de travail
par contre je vais essayer de vous
donner quelques éléments de cadrage sur
le problème à traiter
vous allez voir que il est
malheureusement beaucoup moins simple
que l'idée qu'on peut s'en faire quand
on lit le ventre ou travail un certain
nombre de vos anciens non pardon je paie
des salaires alors d'abord on va
commencer par allonger un peu l'âge du
départ à la retraite
il paraît que cet homme est parti à la
retraite et on va commencer justement
par rentrer directement dans le vif du
sujet qui est quand on parle d'énergie
de quoi parle-t-on
si je vous pose la question non pas qui
est capable de définir ce que c'est que
l'énergie mais à votre avis c'est quoi
l'énergie alors je vous pose pas la
question juste à vous je pose la
question à la population française dans
son ensemble
la première chose à laquelle les gens
vont penser si je leur parle énergie
c'est pas du tout physique c'est argent
les gens vont penser à l'argent donc les
gens ils vont vous répondre
immédiatement l'énergie c'est un truc
qui s'achète
donc c'est une facture en gros donc
l'énergie c'est une facture
d'électricité c'est une facture de gaz
quelques audacieux me parleront de leur
facture de carburant surtout s'ils sont
gilet jaune
mais voilà ce qu'on va avoir
immédiatement en tête c'est l'énergie
c'est une facture donc si on parle
d'énergie ce qui est important c'est de
savoir si ça coûte cher aux pas cher et
puis fatalement lien avec le reste de la
de la manière dont la société évolue on
confie sa trois ingénieurs si l'éolien
vaut moins cher que le nucléaire en fait
de l'éolien vous allez voir que
malheureusement c'est la mauvaise
réponse ou en tout cas c'est une
mauvaise réponse
et la raison est très simple c'est que
si vous regardez ce que vous coûte
vraiment l'énergie
alors je vais vous poser la question qui
dans cette salle paye une facture
d'électricité ou de gaz en direct qui
dans cette salle parmi ceux qui ont levé
la main est capable de me répondre
instantanément quel était le montant ma
dernière facture donc vous en avais chez
pas à vue de nez 15 % de ceux qui ont
levé la main avant qu par contre qui
dans cette salle loue un appartement et
qui est capable de me dire qu'elle est
quel était le montant de son dernier
loyer c'est les mêmes d'accord donc ce
que je viens de vous montrer c'est que
l'énergie c'est une suffisamment petite
facture pour que ça ne soit pas présent
dans votre esprit comme étant quelque
chose de significatif dans vos dépenses
et de fait c'est une petite facture
quand vous regardez ce qu'on dépense
pour les achats d'énergie que ce soit au
sein des ménages ou pour l'économie dans
son ensemble
vous allez tomber alors selon la
personne qui achète selon l'énergie etc
sur quelque chose qui représente
quelques pour cent de nos dépenses si je
vous le dit autrement les là le chiffre
d'affaires des acteurs énergétiques dans
le pib mondial
ces quelques pour cent du pib la valeur
du pétrole qu'on achète tous les ans par
exemple sur les marchés ces 3 % du pib
mondial
donc si je regarde ce que vaut l'énergie
en termes de factures ces quelques pour
cent de nos dépenses et à ce moment homo
economicus rational us va se dire si ces
quelques pour cent de mes dépenses je
vais y passer quelques pour cent du
temps fermer le ban le reste du temps je
m'occupe de choses sérieuses et c'est
très exactement comme ça que résonne la
quasi totalité du monde des décideurs
économiques politiques et des hauts
fonctionnaires
c'est une facture quelques pourcents de
ce qu'on dépense on s'en occupe quelques
pour cent du temps etc
alors malheureusement ce raisonnement
est à peu près aussi
pertinent que si je vous dit votre
cervelle ces 2 % de votre poids et soit
dit en passant chez les hommes la
testostérone c'est beaucoup moins que 2
% du poids
donc vous pouvez vous en occupez 2 % du
temps puis le reste du temps c'est pas
la peine
d'accord il est absolument évident que
si je vous enlève la moitié de votre
cervelle vous allez avoir quelques
petits problèmes dans la vie et si chez
les hommes jean lève la totalité ou chez
les femmes la totalité des estrogènes je
vais à tout petit peu modifié ce qui
vous arrive alors que j'ai touché à
quelque chose qui représente une infime
fraction de votre nas d'accord donc ce
que représente l'énergie en part de nos
dépenses c'est pas le sujet parce que
vous allez vous rendre compte que la
totalité de ce qui fait le monde moderne
en dépend et ses raisonnements
économiques en part de camembert masquer
le lien de dépendance d'une part de
camembert à une autre part de camembert
il ya une autre âneries consiste vous
couramment qui est l'agriculture c'est
2% du pib donc si on s'en passe c'est
pas très grave
sauf que si vous arrêtez de manger les
98 % restants du pib vous pouvez les
oublier aussi donc les raisonnements
empare de camembert fait très très
attention il ya une illusion extrêmement
courante dans ce genre de raisonnement
qui est que ça ne vous donne pas les
liens de dépendance d'une part de
camembert à une autre part de camembert
ne basé jamais jamais jamais un
raisonnement pour l'avenir sur les parts
de camembert sans avoir vérifié que les
parts étaient indépendantes les unes des
autres donc l'énergie ces quelques
pourcents de ce qu'on dépense donc c'est
pas grave si c'est une dépense alors
après la deuxième réponse qu'on va
pouvoir vous faire en ce moment c'est il
faut l'économiser ce qu'on va vous dire
c'est la meilleure énergie est celle
qu'on n'utilise pas et bien perdu si
vous êtes dans cette salle aujourd'hui
entre un drame au lieu d'être en train
de ramasser des patates et bien c'est
justement parce qu'on n'a pas économisé
l'énergie depuis deux siècles ce que je
vais vous raconter dans pas longtemps
la troisième chose qu'on vous raconte
parfois sur l'énergie c'est que il faut
qu'elle soit totalement le vénère alors
je vais vous montrer dans pas longtemps
que totalement ou nrc le monde dont on
sort il ya trois siècles le monde était
100% vénère les trois siècles le monde
utilisait que des énergies renouvelables
que ça nous n'utilisions que la traction
animale la biomasse la force du vent les
moulins à vent et à eau etc on
n'utilisait que ça
et en fait ça fait trois siècles qu'on a
passé notre temps à passer des énergies
renouvelables aux énergies fossiles et
on avait une marine 100% renouvelable
on s'est dit non quand même pour faire
venir les fringues de chez zara
rapidement dans les supermarchés
français c'est pas terrible il faut
beaucoup mieux une manne marine fossiles
ça marche beaucoup mieux et puis on
avait des transports 100% renouvelable
et on s'est dit non quand même pour
faire venir les pêches du sud-ouest ont
rapidement à paris ça marche beaucoup
mieux d'avoir des transports 100%
fossiles c'est beaucoup plus efficace
on avait une agriculture 100%
renouvelable les gens mangeaient des
patates et des oignons il avait mauvaise
haleine et on s'est dit non quand même
pour manger du bifteck à tous les repas
c'est beaucoup mieux d'avoir une
agriculture 100% fossiles c'est beaucoup
plus efficace
on avait des travaux publics 100%
renouvelable donc le canal de suez et
les voies romaines on les faisait à la
pelle et à la pioche et on s'est dit non
quand même pour faire rapidement des
ronds points très importants les ronds
points dans ce pays c'est beaucoup plus
efficace d'avoir des travaux publics
fossiles et donc on a utilisé les
travaux publics fossiles on avait une
construction 100 % renouvelable un
siècle pour faire notre dame en version
en version 2 ça ira plus vite quand même
alors qu'aujourd'hui il faut un an pour
faire une tour à la défense c'est
beaucoup plus efficace d'avoir une
construction 100% fossiles
essentiellement fossiles on avait une
industrie 100% renouvelable basée sur
les moulins et on s'est dit non quand
même pour faire le dernier smartphone à
20 euros par mois c'est beaucoup plus
efficace d'avoir une industrie 100%
facile et nous avions même des séchoirs
à luzerne 100% renouvelable ça s'appelle
le soleil et aujourd'hui on a des
séchoirs à luzerne à gaz parce que c'est
beaucoup plus efficace
donc ça fait deux siècles que nous
passons notre temps à passer des
énergies renouvelables aux énergies
fossiles
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien ondes
et les crétins patenté gelées possibles
après tout un certain nombre de
philosophes qu'ils disent ou bien c'est
que il ya une raison physique profonde
au fait qu'on ait fait ça pendant deux
siècles et c'est ce que je vais essayer
de vous expliquer à partir de maintenant
il ya une raison physique profonde à ce
qu'on ait fait ça et donc ça va pas du
tout être piece of cake comme disent les
anglais de passer à 100% et vénère en
conservant le pouvoir d'achat qu'on a
aujourd'hui et les études longues qui
vous permettent d'étudier ici mon pari
c'est que c'est juste pas possible mais
je vais essayer de le démontrer après
donc on a trois mauvaises réponses
c'est pas une facture on l'a pas
économiser jusqu'à maintenant on va le
voir
et en fait on a passé notre temps à
sortir du monde 100 % renouvelable
en fait la bonne réponse
concerne l'énergie vous allez voir à
partir de maintenant c'est que l'énergie
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'être
superman pour de vrais savent et
superman ou superwoman peu importe il
vole nous voulons pas des avions il a
une force musculaire absolument
monstrueuse il peut arrêter ce qu'il
veut et bien l'énergie c'est ce qui vous
permet de construire des machines qu'ils
arrêtent ce que vous voulez il suffit
que la machine soit suffisamment grosse
le superman il a la possibilité de voir
très loin et bien grâce à l'énergie ont
fait des engins ont fait des prothèses
oculaires qui nous permettent de voir
très très loin ça s'appelle des
satellites ou les télescopes et c'est
donc en fait l'énergie c'est ce qui nous
a permis d'être superman pour de vrai
c'est ça que je vais vous expliquer à
partir de maintenant et c'est bien pour
ça que la drogue est si douce et que
c'est si difficile de s'en passer
alors pour ça je vais avoir besoin de
revenir à de la physique aux heures qui
a fait de la physique dans ses jeunes
années ici avant de rentrer à très bien
donc tous les gens qu'on fait de la
physique normalement ils sont capables
de me définir ce que c'est que l'énergie
ils n'ont pas levé la main tout à
l'heure ou bien ils n'écoutaient pas
alors je vais vous donner alors il ya en
fait les physiciens continue à discuter
sur une manière unique de résumer ce que
c'est que l'énergie ont d'une phrase
mais moi je vais vous donner la mienne
enfin on a à peu près tous d'accord en
fait l'énergie par définition en
physique c'est ce qui compte ici la
transformation de l'environnement
alors je vais vous le dire de manière
encore plus sophistiquées l'énergie
c'est ce qui compte ici le changement
d'état d'un système c'est ça l'énergie
en physique donc dès que vous avez un
système qui change d'état qui change de
température qui change de vitesse qui
change de forme quittent ces échanges de
n'importe quoi vous avez de l'énergie
qui entrent en jeu donc compter
l'énergie ses comptes et la
transformation physique du monde qui
nous entoure
c'est ça l'énergie donc c'est une
grandeur physique avant d'être un sujet
de débat politique
or les grandeurs physiques ont une très
mauvaise idée c'est d'être régi par des
lois qui ne dépendent pas de nous
d'accord donc si vous avez envie parce
que c'est dans un programme politique de
changer la loi de conservation de
l'énergie par un vote à l'assemblée
nationale parce que vous vous dites que
ça ferait bien dans un programme
politique doit toujours y aller je
parais toutes mes économies contre qui
veut qu'il n'y arriverait pas parce que
l'énergie encore une fois c'est une
grandeur physique
régis par des lois qui ne dépendent pas
de nous c'est très désagréable d'avoir
des trucs qui dépendent pas de nous et
on a on a en a justement avec ce siècle
de progrès techniques et de diffus
lyon énergétique on pense qu'on peut
régler absolument tout et s'opposer
absolument alors il ya une loi cardinal
en physique qui régie de l'énergie qui
s'appelle la loi de conservation
alors le dictionnaire est bien fait la
loi de conservation elle dit un truc
très simple elle dit dans un système qui
ne communiquent pas avec l'extérieur la
quantité d'énergie reste rigoureusement
constante au cours du temps c'est pas je
te fais 10 % en plus en moins si je suis
un bon négociateur n'ont rigoureusement
constance donc appliqué aux hommes
ça veut dire que les hommes n'ont pas
d'autres possibilités en ce qui concerne
l'énergie que d'extraire de
l'environnement une énergie qui s'y
trouvent déjà et de l'utiliser à leur
profit alors utiliser de l'énergie en
fait ça veut dire en pratique la mettre
dans un convertisseur c'est à dire que
vous rentrez l'énergie dans un système
physique qui va vous en sortir autre
chose
historiquement le seul système physique
que les hommes ont utilisé ou le premier
système physique plus exactement que les
hommes ont utilisé ces deux mêmes
c'est donc le nous nous sommes notre
premier convertisseur d'énergie et
l'énergie qu'on met dedans ça s'appelle
manger mais miam parfois par l'eau
enfin dans les pays dans lesquels on a
de quoi donc le premier convertisseur
qui a été utilisé par les hommes c'est
leur propre organisme
alimentée par une énergie qui est
l'alimentation et nous en sortons de
choses de la chaleur beaucoup parce que
nous sommes des animaux à sang chaud du
mouvement un peu et la capacité à
raconter trois trucs intéressants au
moins intéressant devant un micro c'est
du mouvement et puis avec le temps on
s'est rendu compte que l'on pouvait
exploiter à notre profit d'autres
sources d'environnement d'autres sources
d'énergie disponibles dans
l'environnement et ça a été justement
les énergies renouvelables donc le bois
le vent la force de l'eau et c'est qu'on
a confiées à d'autres convertisseur
alors certains biologique par exemple la
biomasse on peut la confier à un
convertisseur biologique qui s'appelle
un animal de trait et à ce moment on
démultiplie déjà une première fois notre
force musculaire mais on peut aussi la
confier à un convertisseur inerte
par exemple un moulin truqués pas un
être vivant et ça va aussi démultiplier
notre force musculaire et puis on a
comme ça utilisé à peu près toutes les
énergies renouvelables disponibles pour
augmenter la capacité qu'on avait à
transformer l'environnement
et puis un jour il ya des ingénieurs
géniaux qui sont arrivés en dix ans et
moi j'ai beaucoup mieux que ça monsieur
j'ai un truc qui s'appelle le moteur
alors le moteur c'est un autre
convertisseur tout à fait inerte aussi
fait de métal et qui est capable de
manger une énergie que vous vous êtes
pas capables de manger parce que vous ne
mangez pas du pétrole enfin vous buvez
pas du pétrole joue pas terrible je ne
conseille pas mais par contre ces
convertisseurs là sont capables
d'exploiter à leur profit des énergies
dont nous ne faisons rien du pétrole du
gaz du charbon voire de l'uranium et
d'en sortir des quantités de
transformation de l'environnement
absolument considérable par rapport à ce
que nos muscles sont capables de faire
et donc nous avons cru et multipliez ce
qui veut dire qu'à partir de maintenant
à chaque fois que vous verrez énergie
quelque part dans un article de journal
un discours etc vous barrez énergie et
vous remplacez par machine dit autrement
utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie c'est
utiliser de plus en plus de machines
alors la quantité d'énergie que vous
utilisez vous il y en a une petite
partie que vous voyez en direct
l'immensité vous ne la voyez pas
personne n'est rentré tout nu dans cette
salle c'est interdit en france du reste
alors ce que vous avez fait pour ne pas
être tout nu c'est que vous êtes habillé
ce matin et bien en vous habillant vous
avez utilisé à votre profit des milliers
de machine vous en êtes même pas rendu
compte
tous ceux qui ont des fibres naturelles
du coton du lin etc ont utilisé sans
s'en rendre compte
des tracteurs des moissonneuses
batteuses des machines qui ont entreposé
ça dans des silos des camions qui ont
transporté ça jusqu'à des filatures des
filatures des usines de produits
chimiques qui ont fait la teinture etc
vous en êtes même pas rendu compte mais
vous avez utilisé tous à votre profit si
vous êtes vêtu avec des fibres
synthétiques donc tous les polymachin
chouette
eh bien vous avez utilisé des dérivés du
pétrole
donc vous avez utilisé sans vous en
rendre compte une plate forme pétrolière
une raffinerie un vapocraqueur etc et
tout ça vous l'avez fait en alors même
si vous êtes très mal réveillé le matin
on était quand même pas un quart d'heure
à vous habiller enfin sauf si vous êtes
devant votre garde-robe à hésiter donc
ça va très très vite d'accord donc en
une minute vous avez exploité des
milliers de machines à votre profit je
pourrais vous décrire tous les actes de
la vie courante que vous faites jusque
jusqu'à ce que vous soyez rentrer dans
cette salle chacun de ses actes exploite
des milliers de machines des dizaines de
milliers de machines à votre profit mais
vous vous en rendez pas compte et
l'énergie vous utilisez elle est
essentiellement là
alors pour montrer à quel point ces
machines sont surpuissantes par rapport
à nos carcasse je vais faire un petit
exercice donc nous sommes à la rentrée
donc certains d'entre vous ont peut-être
était faire un peu de montagne qui était
faire un peu de montagne dans cette
salle pendant l'été quelques-uns qui ont
transpiré alors le but de la montagne
c'est de monter sinon c'est pas de la
montagne ça s'appelle une randonnée en
brousse donc vous partez tôt le matin et
on imagine que vous allez faire dans la
journée deux mille mètres de dénivelé
qui a fait 2000 mètres de dénivelé dans
une journée cet été il y en a moins
bravo et bien si vous faites de 1000
mètres de dénivelé alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas la possibilité de partir à la
montagne vous avez une variante sais
vous allez faire 6,3 fois à la tour
eiffel
ça marche très bien aussi à pied un pas
dans l'ascenseur et les japonais eux
bien vous faites également de 1000
mètres de dénivelé et bien en faisant
cet effort et on y sent votre carcasse
donc sur 2000 m de dénivelé la quantité
d'énergie fournie par vos jambes parce
que les antipodistes sont rares dans ce
genre d'exercice
ça va être un ridicule demi
kilowattheure donc vous transpirez
pendant toute la journée
transpire un peu quand on fait deux
mille mètres vous transpirez pendant
toute la journée vous êtes quand même
content de la soupe que vous allez
manger le soir et bien un demi
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique c'est
tout ce que vos jambes ont été capables
de fournir pour un effort de cette
nature si vous faites ça un jour sur
deux et donc par exemple comme da pour
ceux qui ont vu sa lane divergent pas si
vous avez vu ça aussi c'est trop vieux
pour vous ce film avec vous pédaler sur
un vélo là toute la journée tous les
jours que dieu fait et c'est pour
fournir de l'énergie à la fin de l'année
vous aurez vos jambes ont fourni un
effort de l'ordre de 100 kilowatts
heures vous aurez fournit 100 kilowatts
heure d'énergie
si vous êtes dans les travaux publics et
que vous pelletée de la terre avec les
bras de monsieur schwarzenegger et que
vous décaissé 15 tonnes de terre dans la
journée pas mal qu'un stop de
terre-neuve a fait six mètres cubes soit
un gros trop gros géraniums et bien vous
êtes dix fois plus ridicule que la
personne qui monte sur une montagne
puisque c'est 0,05 kilowattheure que
vous aurez fourni dans la journée avec
vos bras un peu avec votre dos et avec
dans pool donc si vous faites ça un jour
sur deux pareils à la fin de l'année
vous aurait fourni 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique donc route n'est
qu'un homme au travail de force
c'est capable de fournir de 10 à 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique dans
l'année et je vous rappelle que
l'énergie c'est la capacité à
transformer l'environnement
si maintenant vous prenez un litre
d'essence dont vous savez évidemment
avec l'actualité récente qui coûte le
prix scandaleusement élevés de 20 euros
monstrueusement cher et bien dans un
litre d'essence
vous avez dit kilowattheures d'énergie
thermique vous fait passer ça dans un
moteur vous avez 2 à 4 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique c'est à dire que
dans 1 litre d'essence qui coûte le prix
scandaleusement élevé de 1 euro 50
vous avez la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement dans un litre 1 insiste
que dans 10 à 100 jours de travail de
force d'un être humain un litre et les
français en consomment des centaines de
litres par an chacun si maintenant on
parle argent puisque au fond il ya que
ça qui nous intéresse est bien le
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique du en
sommes au travail d'une femme au travail
va me coûter en occident si je le paye
au smic de quelques centaines à quelques
milliers d'euros le kilowattheure alors
qu'en face la machine me rend le même
service pour un coût marginal de
quelques dizaines de centimes dont je
vous le redis encore autrement quand on
est passé de l'homme à la machine
on a été capable de diviser en l'espace
d'un siècle et demi
le coût unitaire d'une transformation de
l'environnement par quelques centaines à
quelques milliers
le pouvoir d'achat promis par les
politiques
il est là il n'est pas du tout dans le
fait que c'est des gens plus
intelligents que la moyenne ce qui prend
le cas du reste il est dans le fait que
la physique nous a permis d'exploiter
des convertisseurs à notre profit qui
ont démultiplié notre capacité de
transformation de l'environnement par
des facteurs inimaginable dont personne
n'a conscience et donc je vous fais dans
pas longtemps l'économie ne reflète
absolument pas cette réalité
imaginons maintenant je prenne un
esclave donc ça reste entre nous parce
que c'est interdit par la loi et que les
gens qui aiment bien ça sont rares donc
si vous prenez un esclave
en règle générale c'est quelqu'un pour
qui c'est pas une vocation de jeunesse
si je pose la question dans cette salle
qui a envie de faire esclaves après ses
études
bien sûr je l'obtiendrai beaucoup de
mains levées donc ça veut dire que si
vous prenez un esclave vous devez
prendre quelqu'un qui a aucune envie de
faire ça donc vous allez devoir payer
pour qu'on aille le chercher contre sa
volonté
payer ensuite c'est à dire investir des
moyens pour l'empêcher de [ __ ] le camp
vous trucider comme dans django etc vous
allez quand même de voir le nourrir et
vous allez devoir l'empêcher de mourir
parce que sinon vous perdez votre actif
et bien si vous mettez boutabout tous
ses coups vous vous rendez compte que
même un esclave va vous coûter 10 à 100
fois plus cher que la machine qui n'est
pas syndiqué qui ne se met pas en grève
qui travaillent h 24 donc la raison pour
laquelle l'esclavagé a disparu en
occident selon moi c'est tout simplement
c'est pas du tout parce que notre code
génétique fait de nous des gens bons
alors qu'il ya deux siècles nous étions
malfaisants et on a exactement le même
code génétique n'en déplaise à laurent
alexandre non c'est juste parce que pour
le moment ça n'a aucune espèce de
rationalité économique de s'emmerder à
servir ses semblables
je sais quand même emmerdant alors que
la machine fait ça pour beaucoup moins
cher et sans heurter la moralité de
quiconque
donc c'est le pétrole qui a sauvé les
esclaves ce n'est pas du tout notre code
génétique qui a changé voilà quelques
premiers éléments sur pourquoi on s'est
mis à consommer de l'énergie de façon
importante
alors maintenant si je regarde les
machines qui utilisent de l'énergie
comment elle se compare par rapport à
nous vous vous rappelez pour tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont fait les études de
physique mentionné précédemment que l'on
passe de l'énergie à la puissance en
faisant intervenir le temps et donc si
je regarde n'ont pas l'énergie mais la
puissance comparer d'un être humain et
des machines qu'on utilise
voilà ce que j'obtiens avec mes 10 à 100
kilowatts heure par an ça revient à dire
qu'un homme au travail il a une
puissance qui va de 10 à 100 watts
d'accord qui connaît ici la puissance
d'une ampoule électrique incandescence
dont personne n'a acheté dans pool dans
cette salle il ya pas une personne qui
sait ce que c'est que la puissance d'une
ampoule à incandescence vont bien oui
c'est ça l'ordre de grandeur ces
quelques dizaines de watts
ça se balade entre 10 et 100
en ordre de grandeur donc ça veut dire
qu'un homme au travail
il a en gros la puissance absorbée je
dis bien absorbé d'une ampoule
électrique beaucoup je pense que vous en
pensez moi je trouve que ça fait pas bon
maintenant je prends n'importe quelle
machine qu'on utilise et vous allez voir
qu'on ait deux trois quatre heures de
grandeur au dessus je prends un tracteur
et bien un tracteur il a la même
puissance mécanique que quelques
centaines de paires de jambes
donc je prends je donne un tracteur à un
agriculteur et je peut évacuer deschamps
quelques dizaines à quelques centaines
d'agriculteurs qui s'y trouvait aussi et
leur faire faire autre chose
c'est-à-dire ouvriers puis employé de
bureau et étudiant à sciences po
un engin de travaux publics ou
consultants pareil un engin de travaux
publics
il développe la même puissance que
quelques milliers de paires de bras
c'est grâce à ça qu'aujourd'hui on fait
les ronds points magiques en quelques
mois ou en quelques semaines ou même
parfois en quelques jours alors qu'avant
il fallait des années de travail avec
les pelles et les pioches pour arriver
au même résultat un camion développe la
même puissance que 4000 fois les jambes
du conducteur un avion pour ça que le
pilote d'avion et mieux payés que le
chauffeur de camion développe la même
puissance que un million de fois les
jambes du pilote est soit dit en passant
un gros avion de ligne à la même
puissance que un gros laminoir qui est
opérée à l'instant où je vous parle par
une personne sert pour ceux d'entre vous
et celles d'entre vous qui ont visité le
laminoir de fos-sur-mer jeu pas si
quelqu'un l'a déjà fait ici
installations que j'ai visité un instant
donné
il ya une personne dans la cabine de
pilotage qui maîtrisent
100 millions de watts de puissance
je vous rappelle que la puissance d'un
homme c'est 100 watts avec ses jambes
d'accord donc le type avec joystick
il a multiplié sa puissance musculaire
par un million si je supprime le
laminoir de fos-sur-mer et que je dis je
vais prendre des gens qui tapent sur des
tôles avec des marteaux pour arriver au
même résultat
eh bien je prends toute l'ile-de-france
vous compris moi compris
je nous donne des marteaux et on tape
sur des tôles toute la journée c'est
tout ce qu'on fait pour remplacer un
laminoir conduit à l'instant où je vous
parle par une personne donc voilà à quoi
ça sert l'énergie ça sert à mettre en
mouvement ces monstres de métal de
plastique et de pierres qui sont
capables d'avoir fait de nous superman
pour de vrai d'avoir fait que new super
man ou iron man comme vous voulez alors
cette énergie que nous utilisons pour la
mettre dans des convertisseurs voilà
comment elle a évolué par personne
depuis un siècle et demi il ya un siècle
et demi l'essentiel de l'énergie qu'on
utilisait c'était du bois donc des
dérivés de la biomasse ça servait
essentiellement à produire de la chaleur
donc cela alimentait des poils pour se
chauffer et ça a servi également à
alimenter le début des machines que on a
été capable de mettre au point cette
époque des forges savoir qu'en france
les forges occasionnait de la
déforestation et ont occasionné une
déforestation croissante jusqu'en 1850
et que c'est le charbon qui a sauvé les
forêts françaises
parce que on a arrêté d'utiliser du bois
pour les forges on utilisait également
le bois pour les premières machines à
vapeur de l'époque lorsque vous voyez
c'est que le bois par personne on en
utilise de moins en moins depuis un
siècle et demi mais comme il ya beaucoup
plus de monde comme on verra après en
quantité totale ça évolue pas de la même
manière
et vous voyez que toutes les autres
énergies que nous avons utilisée après
le bois sont toutes en utilisation
croissante ou constante et l s'empilent
les unes sur les autres
c'est à dire qu'à ce jour il n'ya pas
macroscopiquement de substitution
d'énergie dans le monde on rajoute les
énergies les unes sur les autres
alors après le bois on s'est mis à
utiliser du charbon et vous voyez que la
quantité de charbon utilisé par personne
n'a jamais des crues dans le monde
depuis qu'on a commencé à utiliser du
charbon il n'y a jamais eu de baisse de
la quantité de charbon utilisé dans le
monde alors une des raisons à cela c'est
que le charbon aujourd'hui c'est la
première source de production électrique
dans le monde
c'est à dire que la première le premier
mode de production électrique dans le
monde sait les centrales à charbon verra
ça dans pas longtemps et ça utilise deux
tiers du charbon qui sort d'une mine
dans sur cette planète et l'électricité
c'est la forme d'énergie qui
augmente le plus vite actuellement le
pétrole est venue se rajouter au charbon
il sert pas du tout à la même chose le
pétrole dans le monde il sert
essentiellement à la mobilité donc les
centrales au charbon sert
essentiellement l'électricité le pétrole
sert essentiellement à la mobilité
avant toute chose après on a eu le gaz
après on a eu les héros électricité et
puis dernièrement on a les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables alors ramené à
l'individu les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables c'est les 3 petits machins
du aulas dont on vous explique que dans
les 30 ans qui viennent parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut faire pour l'accord de
paris ça va remplacer tout le reste dans
un approvisionnement énergétique
croissante puisqu'il faut bien que la
croissance économique ait lieu alors
s'il ya des quelques courageux dans
cette salle je veux bien prendre les
paris avec qui veut la sortie de cette
salle que dans les 30 ans qui viennent
n'auront pas 100% on vénère remplaçants
tout ça par personne et même cette
entité en croissance s'il ya des gens
qui sont prêts à prendre le pari je veux
bien y aller et on n'y arrivera pas pour
des raisons physiques
voilà donc un monde sans fous
sanguinaires mais j'y reviendrai à la
fin de cet exposé c'est un monde dans
lequel notre pouvoir d'achat il est
divisé par n'importe quoi entre 5 et 40
donc on peut très bien le faire
strictement aucun problème je veux dire
physiquement on peut le faire
ça n'est sûrement pas un monde qui
correspond à la situation économique
actuelle
alors qui par ailleurs va pas durer non
plus donc ça finalement peut-être qu'on
va y arriver quand même voilà mais j'en
profite pour vous dire une chose
vous voyez là l'importance quantitative
des nerfs dans le monde par rapport aux
autres formes d'énergie à l'évidence ça
n'est absolument pas reflété par
l'importance de ces sujets là dans la
pagination du journal et donc je vais
être un peu taquin avec vos anciens qui
travaillent dans les médias et vous
donner quelque chose que je j'espère
vous allez garder en mémoire parce que
ça sera très utile pour piloter votre
vie future quoi que vous fassiez ne
prenez jamais ce qu'il y a dans la
presse comme une source opposable je
répète ne prenez jamais ce qu'il y a
dans la presse comme une source
opposable la presse c'est la fin d'un
téléphone arabe qui a déjà joué au
téléphone arabe dans cette salle quand
il était petit alors parmi les mains qui
se lèvent qui a constaté qu'à la fin de
la boucle du téléphone arabe
on avait toujours dans tous les cas de
figure strictement la même chose qu'au
début on est d'accord
personne si une fois vous y avez joué
combien de fois une fois et avec trois
personnes n'ont donc la presse c'est la
fin d'un téléphone arabe dont vous ne
connaissez ni le nombre de maillots ni
la qualité de la transmission entre
chaque maillon ni la source de
l'information pour le premier maillon de
la chaîne
et comme vous le savez la résistance
d'une chaîne c'est la résistance de son
maillon le plus faible
donc à partir du moment où vous ne savez
pas ce que vaut l'information de départ
et vous ne savez pas ce que vaut la
qualité de transmission de la formation
d'un maillon à l'autre avant que ça
arrive aux journalistes vous ne savez
pas quelle est la fiabilité de
l'information vous avez en face de vous
donc je le répète et c'est
particulièrement vrai pour les sujets
techniques
ne prenez jamais ce qu'il y a dans la
presse comme une source opposable c'est
très agréable de vous dire ça ça veut
dire que le boulot que vous pensiez
pouvoir vous éviter de tri et d'analysé
de hauteur de vue sur l'information est
fait par quelqu'un qui va bien le faire
et d'un manque de pot c'est pas le cas
c'est utile de le savoir parce que ça
vous évitera bien des déconvenues
j'en profite pour vous dire une autre
chose qui est une autre grande règle de
vie cette occasion qui est vous avez été
sélectionné pour rentrer ici avec des
problèmes bien posée qui n'admet qu'une
seule solution
enfin en tout cas en sciences la vie ça
n'est que des problèmes mal posée qui
admettent plusieurs solutions dont
qu'une partie de ce que vous apprenez à
l'école ne vous ai strictement d'aucune
utilité pour gérer les problèmes de la
ligne ça ne sera que des problèmes mal
posée par exemple avec une information
inexacte et qui admettent plusieurs
solutions
je reviens à mon énergie donc donc ce
que vous voyez c'est que la quantité
d'énergie mobilisés par personne c'est à
dire la quantité de machines mobilisés
par personne a considérablement augmenté
en l'espace d'un siècle et demi c'est ça
la révolution industrielle et ses sages
insiste encore une fois qui fait
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat de la
population
si je regarde aujourd'hui l'essentiel de
ce qui fait notre pouvoir d'achat c'est
donc des énergies fossiles alors le
dictionnaire et bienfaits des énergies
fossiles cd reste de vie ancienne en
face à l'eire est ancien c'est des
choses qui ont fossilisés donc les
énergies fossiles ces gaz pétrole
charbon puisque c'est des restes de vie
ancienne l'uranium n'est pas une énergie
fossile
c'est un métal les métaux ne sont pas
considérés comme des faux cils donc le
cuivre est pas considéré comme un
fossile
non plus d'uranium non plus c'est
disponible en quantité finie
évidemment mais par contre c'est pas
faux seins et les énergies fossiles
étant des restes de vie ancienne et la
vie sûre c'est sur terre étant basé sur
des chaînes carbonées
elles ont toutes comme caractéristique
commune de conduire à des émissions de
co2 quand on s'en sert puisque libérer
l'énergie d'une énergie fossile c'est
oxydé le carbone et d'hydrogène qui s'y
trouvent donc vous n'utilisez pas
d'énergies fossiles sans faire du co2
c'est impossible et la quantité
d'énergie
aulas et la quantité d'énergie un peu
vite la quantité d'énergie que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui en moyenne
mondiale
ça fait vingt mille kilowatts heure par
personne et par an et avec le petit
calcul d'ordre de grandeur que je vous
ai fait juste avant sur comment se
comparent la puissance musculaire et la
puissance des machines ça revient à dire
que chaque terrien grâce aux machines
qu'ils mobilisent à travers cette
quantité d'énergie a multiplié sa
puissance productive par 201 multiplié
sa puissance musculaire par 200 donc
l'énergie qui permet de mettre en route
des machines à 2 fait multiplier la
capacité de transformation de
l'environnement de chaque terrien par un
facteur de son je vais vous le dire
encore autrement
nous sommes un peu plus de 7 milliards
sur terre s'il n'y avait pas les
machines et l'énergie pour avoir la même
production annuelle
il faudrait qu'on soit 1400 milliards ça
poserait à tout petit problème de
nourriture donc les machines ont permis
j insiste de faire de nous superman pour
de vrai alors en occident c'est pas 200
le multiple c'est entre 500 et 1000 et
pour les csp + que vous êtes
majoritairement c'est plutôt entre 1000
et 2000 donc vous dans cette salle vous
vivez mois dans cette salle je dis pas
ce que je fais partie de la même
catégorie
exactement comme si j'avais mille à deux
mille esclaves à ma disposition en
permanence le smicard français grâce à
l'énergie vit aujourd'hui comme un nabab
c'est ça le drame politique de cette
affaire vous pouvez pas lui dire mais
c'est la réalité
c'est ça le drame politique de cette
affaire et même le mode de vie du
smicard français ça qu'on va voir dans
pas longtemps n'est pas durable c'est à
dire qu'il est déjà trop élevé par
rapport à ce que la nature est capable
de nous offrir en combustible en
capacité d'épuration du co2 etc
c'est ça encore une fois le tram
politique indicible de cette affaire
alors vos esclaves des temps modernes en
voici un tout petit sous ensemble et en
plus ces esclaves des temps modernes
dont la très bonne idée par rapport aux
esclaves des temps anciens qui étaient
les animaux de trait et les organismes
humains de manger du sous sol parce que
les animaux de trait nous faisait
concurrence sur l'alimentation autre
fois il leur fallait des surfaces pour
se nourrir c'était autant de surface
qu'on pouvait pas utilisé pour nourrir
les hommes
les esclaves il fallait les surfaces
pour les nourrir c'était autant de
surface que vous pouviez pas utilisé
pour nourrir les gens dits libres le la
les esclaves des temps modernes mange du
sous sol dont qui nous laisse tout
l'espace en surface et soit dit en
passant un des problèmes liés aux
énergies renouvelables
ces caisses à recréer de la concurrence
des usages du sol parce que les énergies
renouvelables
elle n utilise pas du sous sol est
utilise du sol donc on retombe sur ce
problème historique de concurrence
d'usagé du sol avec les énergies
renouvelables et donc par individu ça
nous a multiplié notre puissance
musculaire par un facteur 2 cents à 6
ans qui dans cette salle n'a jamais
entendu dire que la france était un pays
tout nucléaire
donc vous lisez le même journal que moi
c'est bien et bien voici l'énergie qui
en france actionne les machines que nous
utilisons alors où est ce qu'on utilise
des machines dans ce pays on utilise des
machines chez nous c'est la colonne
résidentiel on utilise des machines là
où on travaille ça s'appelle tertiaire
on utilise des machines pour fabriquer
des objets ça s'appelle industrie on
utilise des machines pour faire pousser
de la nourriture
ça s'appelle agriculture et on utilise
des machines pour gérer les transports
ça s'appelle transport l'axé vertical
est gradué en milliards de
kilowattheures c'est ça qu'on appelle
des térawattheures et on colle un
kilowattheure ses 3,6 million de joules
je peux utiliser des kilowattheure pour
tous pas juste pour l'électricité jeu
peut en utiliser pour le
charbon pour le pétrole pour le gaz pour
ce que je veux dès qu'il ya de l'énergie
je peux utiliser des kilowattheures et
maintenant je vais cercle et ceux qui
dans ce pays provient des combustibles
fossiles pour les machines que nous
actionnons et maintenant je vous pose la
question pensez vous que la france soit
un pays tout nucléaire qui considère que
c'est une affirmation justifiée quand on
voit ce graphique donc voilà une
application très pratique de ce que je
viens de vous dire tout à l'heure sur ne
croyez pas la presse
ne croyez pas la presse jamais insiste
jamais ça n'est jamais opposable alors
dans le même temps vous avez la
population humaine qui a un tout petit
peu augmenté alors en fait ce n'est pas
dans le même temps c'est grâce à
l'énergie que la population humaine a
augmenté parce que l'énergie a permis
par exemple de supprimer l'essentiel des
famines si ça pousse plus ici on
transporte de là où ça pousse c'est
l'énergie permet de conserver les
aliments l'énergie permet de se protéger
du chaud et du froid
l'énergie permet d'avoir du temps libre
pour chercher sur des médicaments parce
que tant qu'on est occupé à faire
pousser des patates il ya pas beaucoup
de chercheurs en médecine qui s'occupe
d'alléger votre espérance de vie
l'énergie permet de vous protéger des
microbes
quand vous naissez et c'est donc en fait
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
c'est une conséquence directe de
l'accroissement de l'approvisionnement
énergétique
c'est une conséquence directe donc dans
le même temps que nous utilisons de plus
en plus d'énergie par personne c'est à
dire que par personne on transforme de
plus en plus l'environnement
on est de plus en plus nombreux alors
l'insee à l'époque n'était pas
extrêmement performante mais on va dire
qu'au moment où les hommes se
sédentarisent il ya dix mille ans est ce
que vous savez pourquoi les hommes se
sédentariser divisant parce qu'il ya dix
mille ans nous sortons de la dernière
grande transition climatique l'humanité
a connu c'est à dire la déglaciation et
le climat devient stable
le climat a été stable pendant dix mille
ans jusqu'au moment où on a commencé à
tripoter est donc un climat stable
ça permet de commencer à développer des
pratiques qui sont reproductibles d'une
année sur l'autre alors que caen climat
est pas stable vous pouvez pas en
restant au même endroit et nous sommes
les lointains ancêtres de cette
stabilisation du climat puisque
aujourd'hui vous habitez en ville enfin
vous étudiez en ville la création de
l'agriculture puis derrière des villes
parce que sans agriculture ya pas de vie
c'est une conséquence de la
stabilisation du climat donc il ya dix
mille ans le climat commence à se
stabiliser et à l'époque même si l'insee
est pas très performante nous sommes
quelques millions sur terre au début de
la révolution industrielle
on a quand même gagné un facteur 100 en
ordre de grandeur enfin un facteur de
quelques dizaines et nous sommes de
l'ordre du milliard et puis là vous
voyez quand deux siècles craque on est
passé à 7 milliards
et ça continue à augmenter quand je suis
né
la population humaine était la moitié de
ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
alors certes je suis un vieux crabes à
vos yeux mais quand même ça fait une
grosse augmentation sur une durée de vie
alors question est ce que quand on voit
ce genre d'évolution on se dit que la
population va rester stable indéfiniment
à 7 ou 8 milliards d'habitants moi je
suis pas complètement persuadés et je
suis même raisonnablement persuadé du
contraire
donc dans les régulations auquel il faut
s'attendre dans les décennies ou siècle
qui viennent il y aura notamment une
contraction de la population qui va
s'opérer d'une façon je suis pas capable
de vous prédire mais je suis à peu près
sûr que l aura lieu alors maintenant une
fois que je combine énergie par personne
x variations de la population voilà à
quoi ressemble la quantité totale
d'énergie c'est-à-dire le parc de
machines que nous mettons en mouvement
sur terre et vous voyez en haut là le
petit machin là qui excite tout le monde
alors que l'essentiel de cette énergie
qui met en mouvement l'essentiel du parc
mondial de machines c'est du carbone
c'est-à-dire des énergies fossiles
même si je regarde la façon dont ça
variait récemment ce que vous allez dire
oui mais jusqu'à maintenant on
s'occupait pas de la transition
maintenant on a mis en route la
transition alors maintenant ça va mieux
voilà comment à varier la quantité
d'énergie utilisée sur terre ce depuis
l'an 2000
depuis l'an 2000 2000 c'est pas très
vieux normalement vous étiez né et bien
pas de beaucoup mais quand même donc
voyez depuis en gros l'âge de votre
naissance comment avariée la quantité
d'énergie qu'on utilise sur terre pour
chacune d énergie qu on utilise sur
terre ce graphique ne vous donne pas la
quantité qu'on utilise aujourd'hui mais
l'augmentation ou la baisse entre 2000
et 2010 8 eh bien vous voyez que ce qui
a le plus augmenté entre 2000 et 2010 8
et de très très loin
c'est pas du tout les énergies
renouvelables c'est les énergies
fossiles
sur cette période le charbon par exemple
a augmenté 5 à 10 fois plus que les deux
énergies renouvelables dont on adore
parler dans ce pays c'est à dire
l'éolien et le solaire
alors que soit dit en passant la
première sur terre c'est
l'hydroélectricité qui a plus augmenté
que l'éolien et le solaire sur la
période mais vous voyez que le
différentiel reste encore en faveur des
énergies fossiles alors je vais vous le
dire d'une autre manière c'est pas moi
qui ai inventé ça mais je trouve ça très
rigolo si vous buvez une bouteille de
whisky par semaine et que votre médecin
vous dit vous devriez quand même y aller
mollo vous dit pas de problème je passe
à une virgule deux bouteilles de whisky
mais je rajoute un verre de jus d'orange
est-ce que vous pensez que votre foi à
voit sa condition s'améliorer c'est
exactement ce que nous avons fait sur
les 18 dernières années nous sommes
passés de une bouteille à une bouteille
et demi de whisky en rajoutant un peu de
jus d'orange et de vitamine c par dessus
voilà ce qu'on a fait depuis un ciré
depuis 18 ans on n'est pas du tout en
train de régler notre problème
pas du tout du tout du tout du tout pas
du tout on est en train d'accroître
notre problème en ayant rajouté par
dessus un zeste de machin qui dit que ça
va bien je vous parlais de l'électricité
tout à l'heure alors une partie de
l'énergie qu'on utilise commence par
transité par une centrale électrique
d'une centrale électrique c'est une
c'est un convertisseur comme d'autres
machines qui prend de l'énergie
disponible dans l'environnement du
pétrole du gaz du charbon de l'uranium
des chutes d'eau etc et qui en sort une
autre forme d'énergie qui s'appelle de
l'électricité le l'essentiel des
centrales électriques dans le monde sont
des machines thermiques cirque on
commence par faire de la chaleur
avec cette chaleur ont fait de la vapeur
et avec cette vapeur ont fait tourner
une turbine c'est-à-dire un alternateur
et ont fait de l'électricité cette
chaleur peut être produite par du
charbon c'est 40 % d'électricité dans le
monde et ça fait 1 kg de co2 par
kilowattheure électrique
ça peut être fait par du gaz c'est 25%
de l'électricité dans le monde
et ça peut être fait par du pétrole ces
quelques pour cent de l'électricité dans
le monde
après vous avez encore un mode thermique
c'est le nucléaire ça fait 10 grammes en
gros de co2 par kilowattheure
et le premier mode renouvelable et non
thermiques on n'a pas besoin de chaleur
pour faire l'électricité c'est
l'hydroélectricité ou là c'est
directement le mouvement de l'eau qui
entraîne la turbine mais tous les autres
modes sont thermiques ce qui veut dire
soit dit en passant que tous les autres
modes c'est des machines de carnot qui
ont besoin de source froide donc toutes
les centrales thermiques en bord de
rivière ont ces grandes tours de
refroidissement qui en france sont
l'emblème de la centrale nucléaire
sauf que si vous allez voir une centrale
en bord de mer ya pas ce genre de trucs
donc vous allez à penly il n'y a pas de
tours de refroidissement pour une
centrale nucléaire
par contre si vous allez voir une
centrale à charbon allemandes en bord de
rivière vous avez cette grande tour de
refroidissement
donc ces grandes tours de
refroidissement s'est pas l'emblème de
la centrale nucléaire c'est l'emblème de
la centrale thermique en bord de rivière
autre chose que la presse
vous êtes civile alors que c'est pas une
bonne assimilation l'assimilation ses
tours de refroidissement centrale
thermique c'est pas tour de
refroidissement centrales nucléaires
pourquoi est-ce que le nucléaire est
décarbonée parce que vous avez un
rapport 1 à 1 million entre l'énergie
que vous retirez d'une combustion et
l'énergie que vous retirez d'une fiction
pour la même quantité de matière de
départ dit autrement si je fis 6 en 1
gramme d'uranium
c'est comme si je fais brûler une tonne
de pétrole donc le nucléaire manipule
des très petites quantités de matière
donc même si vous avez des engins de
mines qui fonctionnent au diesel de
l'enrichissement nécessaire à toute la
chaîne du combustible traitement des
déchets derrière comme ça manipule des
toutes petites quantités de matière
rapporté au kilowattheure produit ça
fait pas beaucoup de co2 c'est pas parce
qu'on peut manger juste pour des raisons
physiques et l'hydroélectricité n'en
fait pas beaucoup non plus parce qu'une
fois que vous avez construit le barrage
dont couler du béton ce qui émet du co2
à spa après que j'en avais plus et les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables vous
voyez ce que ça représente en eau et
elles sont pas non plus zéro carbone
parce que pour faire un panneau solaire
vous avez besoin de 20 mhz et aux
différents donc il faut les fondre et
fondre des métaux ça émet du co2 il faut
faire baver d'allergies de l'acier davet
a urgé du silicium de la métallurgie du
cuivre etc tout ça crache du co2 donc
vous en avez plus ou moins en fonction
du collecteur que vous allez utiliser si
vous utilisez un panneau solaire et que
vous stockez l'électricité sur batterie
vous pouvez arriver à quasiment 200
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure ça se
balade entre 50 et 200 et pour mémoire
le ski le water eau gaz c'est 400
kilowattheure électrique au gaz c'est
400 donc vous voyez que c'est pas du
tout vers c'est moins carboné que le gaz
ça c'est une affirmation précise vert
c'est pas précis il reste électricité
n'est pas verte
si vous mettez vos doigts dans la prise
n'est pas de venir vers l'électricité
c'est de l'électricité vous n'allez pas
vous transformer en hulk si vous mettez
vos doigts dans la prise ça marche pas
bien
voilà donc ce que vous voyez sur la
production électrique c'est que
l'essentiel et fossiles et l'essentiel
de l'ain crémant alors là je vous ai
même pris simplement les huit dernières
années est aussi faux cils c'est à dire
qu'avant de vous parler des panneaux
solaires qu'on installe chez paou
devrait continuer à vous parler des
centrales à charbon qu'on installe chez
paou parce que c'est ça qui continue à
se passer avant toute chose alors
maintenant je vais vous parler un peu
d'économies parce que dans le système
physique que je vous décris en fait ce
système physique on ne le voit pas au
quotidien parce que ce que vous allez
manipuler au quotidien c'est pas des
kilowattheures n'arrivait pas chez le
marchand de carottes en disant bonjour
les carottes
ça vaut combien de kilowattheures
marchands de carottes vous lui dites
bonjour je dois et carottes combien
d'euros donc en fait le seul indicateur
quantitatif que vous manipulez tous les
jours c d euros d'accord avec moi vous
en manipuler un autre qui est le temps
celui-là il purement physique et même en
payant très cher en fait pas passer les
journées à plus de 24 heures on s'en
rend bien compte mais par contre
l'indicateur quantitatif que vous allez
manipuler le plus souvent c'est les
autres
alors les euros c'est donc un produit de
l'économie et l'économie a un problème
fondamental avec ce que je viens de vous
exposer c'est qu'elle sait par
construction rendu myope vis-à-vis de la
physique vous avez ici un homme dont
certains d'entre vous et certaines
d'entre vous ont peut-être entendu
parler qui s'appelle monsieur jean
baptiste say qui a entendu parler de
jean baptiste say a il y en a plus
qu'eux
de gens qui savent la définition de
l'énergie alors monsieur jean baptiste
c'est comme un certain nombre de ses
petits copains de l'époque quand ils ont
commencé à théoriser la façon dont on
devait concevoir l'économie
en fait ils ont je vais résumer
l'économie par une phrase que vous
connaissez bien
l'économie c'est la gestion de ce qui
est rare alors moi je vais vous le dire
un peu autrement
l'économie c'est la compréhension des
facteurs limitants dans la production
d'accord qu'est ce que c'est que
l'économie physiquement c'est un système
de transformation c'est juste ça
produire s'est transformée tous les
vêtements que vous avez sur vous ce sont
des ressources transformer les bancs sur
lesquels vous êtes assis enfin les
chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes assis
sont des ressources transformer la salle
dans laquelle nous sommes c'est des
ressources transformer les moyens de
transport qui vous ont permis de venir
ici c'est des ressources transformer
votre smartphone c'est des ressources
transformer le réseau de télécoms qui
vous permettra d'envoyer une vidéo à
votre copain c'est des ressources
transformer tout ça c'est des ressources
transformé
donc nous arrivons sur terre et tout ce
que nous avons été capables de faire
c'est pas mal mais tout ce que nous
avons été capables de faire c'est de
prendre les ressources disponibles sur
terre et les transformer d'accord c'est
ça notre activité productive économique
alors dans cette affaire-là ya deux
siècles nous sommes 1 milliards sur
terre et monsieur sait se dit les
ressources naturelles il y aura autant
qu'on veut alors si on veut sortir des
pierres pour faire sortir des pierres de
tuffeau pour faire des maisons de maître
dans l'anjou bas il y en a autant qu'on
veut donc on va pas s'emmerder à savoir
s'il ya un problème de limites sur la
pierre de tuffeau donc à ce moment on se
dit le seul facteur limitant à ce qu'il
ya deux siècles l'essentiel de
l'activité humaine et agricoles donc on
jeudi les braults voilà le seul truc
limitant pour la production c'est nombre
de gens qui sont capables de travailler
et le capital humain déjà existants qui
à l'époque est essentiellement la terre
le reste est pas la peine de sang vers
des halles compter parce que pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont des vieux souvenirs
de maths
si on considère que le stock de départ
est infinie toute variation relative du
stock est nul donc on va pas s'emmerder
à traîner des zéro partout dans les
équations
c'est un peu c'est un peu ballot donc on
dit allez hop 0 je m'en occupe pas et
donc arrive monsieur jean baptiste say
qui écrit explicitement ce qui est l
axiome de départ de la théorie
économique que nous utilisons encore
aujourd'hui qu'ils aient les ressources
naturelles
c'est gratuit les ressources naturelles
c'est gratuit donc 20% d'oxygène dans
l'air c'est gratuit pourtant si je
retire 20% d'oxygène dans l'air vous
êtes d'accord avec moi que le pib tombe
à zéro je vous mourrez tous et toutes
on est d'accord là dessus donc voilà
quelque chose qui est indispensable à
l'existence d'une activité économique et
qui est invisible dans nos comptes
je vais vous donner un autre exemple le
pétrole est gratuit délire complètement
seul pétrole et gratuit 1 euro 50 les
gilet jaune ce nom le pétrole est
gratuit la formation du pétrole n'a pas
coûté un centime à qui que ce soit dans
cette salle la formation du pétrole
c'est de la vie ancienne qui nous a rien
coûté de la fossilisation par la
géothermie et la tectonique des plaques
qui nous a rien coûté et tout ce que ça
coûte le pétrole c'est de se baisser
pour les ramasser
donc quand vous payez le pétrole ce que
vous payez c'est les ingénieurs de feu
les fleurons français technique et john
berger qui sont maintenant passés
américains puis les ingénieurs de chez
total
puis le consentement à se défaire du
pétrole ou les chars et les avions que
vous en voyez ça dépend des versions des
gens qui en ont c'est ça que ça vous
coûte à aucun moment vous avez payé le
pétrole lui-même et je peux vous refaire
le raisonnement pour l'acier vous n'avez
pas fait les noyaux des atomes de fer
les atomes de fer ont été créés dans la
génération des toiles qui a précédé le
soleil à partir de protons vous ne savez
pas faire ça moi non plus du reste donc
nous arrivons sur terre et du fer il y
en a pleins partout et c'est gratuit
y a qu'à se baisser pour aller ramasser
la formation du fer est gratuite la
formation du cuivre est gratuite la
formation des diamants et gratuite
d'information du platine est gratuite
l'invention de tout ce que nous avons à
disposition sur terre est gratuite c'est
exactement ce qui est écrit là alors si
c'est gratuit la diminution de cet actif
aux héros donc ça ça vaut zéro par
construction
on est d'accord ça ça vaut zéro par
construction il ya quand même un mec qui
a eu le so called prix nobel d'économie
pour avoir fait une fonction de dommages
là dessus alors une fonction de dommages
sur un truc qui vaut zéro par convention
c'est ça ça mérite pas un prix nobel
mais c'est exactement ça mérite une
blague mais ça mérite pas un prix nobel
donc le donc la terre vaut zéro pour
ceux d'entre vous qui ont quelques
notions de base de comptabilité ça
revient à dire que nulle part dans la
formation des prix
nous n'avons une dotation aux
amortissements pour diminution des
ressources naturelles nulle part donc
l'économie qu'on va vous apprendre ici
je suis désolé d'être très désagréable
avec la puissance invitante
elle est basée sur un système de pensée
qui se résume à ça vous avez deux
facteurs productifs qui sont le travail
et le capital humain et ça ça a permis
de remplir le supermarché et si le
supermarché n'est pas assez rempli c'est
à dire que le pouvoir d'achat n'est pas
assez haut
on botte le cul des gens qui veulent pas
travailler on peut être le cul des
banquiers qui veulent pas investir et le
système est censé repartir alors ça fait
dix ans qu'on fait ça dans ce pays et ça
fait dix ans que comme disait ma fille
quand elle avait deux ans et demi ça
mieux pas si c'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe c'est probablement que la
représentation du système n'est pas la
bonne et de fait la représentation du
système n'est pas la bonne la
représentation du système c'est que pour
avoir ce que vous avez à droite qui sont
des ressources transformez vous avez
besoin des ressources à transformer je
leur dis vous ne créez pas tel harry
potter les atomes de cuivre et de fer
qui lie à dans les objets qui
contiennent du métal vous avez besoin de
les trouver dans la nature dont vous
avez besoin de ressources et vous avez
besoin de la capacité à les transformer
ce qu'on appelle du travail et ce
travail avec ce que je vous ai exposé
avant il vient pour un de nos carcasse
et pour 200 des convertisseurs
extracorporelle que nous avons créé et
qui s'appelle superman ou spider man ou
iron man ça dépend quel est votre
comiques préférés de chez marvel
donc ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique
c'est une représentation synthétique
physique de l'économie et là dans le
capital il existe bien c'est une boucle
internes au système c'est à dire que cet
immeuble qui est un élément de capital a
été fait exactement comme vos vêtements
qui n'en sont pas normalement c'est à
dire en transformant des ressources
naturelles la seule différence c'est que
ça suce pas quand on s'en sert cirque
normalement cette salle ne s'écroulera
pas pendant qu'on y est si ça se passe
ça fait les gros titres des journaux
pour une fois à raison
donc le capital c'est juste de la
production c'est à dire des ressources
transformer déjà existantes que nous ré
affectons parce que ça c'est parce que
c' est capable de durer à une
amélioration de la production future
c'est à dire de la transformation futur
de ressources naturelles c'est juste ça
le capital en termes physiques
alors une fois qu on comprend ça on se
dit qu'il ya d'autres facteurs limitants
dans le système et que par exemple si
nous devons avoir un défaut d'énergie
dont vous verrez dans pas longtemps que
ça n'est pas nécessairement donné par le
prix ça c'est encore un truc très
désagréable et je vais vous dire nepad
élasticité-prix volume on verra après si
vous avez un défaut d'énergie et bien
vous aurez un défaut de production même
si vous avez plein de gens prêts à se
lever le matin pour aller travailler et
même si vous avez des banquiers qui sont
extrêmement généreux de toute façon vous
avez un facteur limitant qui s'applique
mais comme monsieur jean baptiste say et
ses copains ont dit l'énergie on s'en
fout c'est une ressource naturelle c'est
gratuit vous ne le voyez pas venir avec
les conventions qu'on utilise donc vous
dites c'est la crise de la dette de
l'acharnement
vous allez voir c'est d'abord la
physique qui s'applique et les
indicateurs mode est d'ailleurs suivent
les si vous avez un défaut de ressources
eh bien vous aurez également à défaut de
production alors qui est allé en
bretagne cet été a pas mal qui sait où
se trouve le guilvinec un peu moins est
ce que vous savez quelle est l'activité
principale du guilvinec la pêche
absolument est ce que vous savez déjà vu
un bateau de pêche
du coup oui alors je vous pose une
question
imaginons que vous ayez un bateau de
pêche avec des tags marin prêt à aller
sur la mer et le crédit maritime prêt à
payer le bateau de pêche d'accord et pas
de diesel pour mettre dans le bateau à
votre avis est-ce que le bateau pêche
les gens prennent des rames et font
avancer le bateau de jeu pourquoi 5000
ou 10000 cheveau non imaginons donc pas
d'énergie pas de pib et puis derrière la
conserverie de douarnenez ne conserve
rien du tout et
le magasin franprix et du coin de la rue
qui vous vend les sardines en boîte ne
pouvant rien du tout cordes on vous
avait pas de pib derrière et
l'administration fiscale ne perçoit pas
de tva sur tout ça si vous avez le
chalutier du guilvinec qui à du fioul
des marins et le crédit coopératif et le
crédit maritime pardon consentants et
qu'il n'y a plus de poissons à pêcher
c'est à dire pas de ressources
eh bien ça marche pas non plus et comme
le disait renault la mer c'est
dégueulasse parce que les poissons
baisse de dents et les poissons
apparaissent tout seul dans la mer parce
qu'il passe dedans et c'est gratuit et
c'est gratuit donc vous utilisez pour
faire le pib de la pêche et toutes les
activités de transformation à laval de
ressources qui sont totalement gratuites
qui s'appelle du pétrole et des poissons
voilà un petit exemple et là vous voyez
bien que dès aujourd'hui
en ce qui concerne la pêche parce que
vous avez tous entendu parler qui en
l'occurrence c'est légitime du problème
de la surpêche
dès aujourd'hui nous avons un problème
de ressources disponibles dans l'océan
qui n'est ni un problème d'effectif dans
la marine ni un problème de banquiers
qui sont prêts à prêter
c'est pas ces problèmes là qui
s'applique c'est un autre c'est un
problème physique qui n'a pas
d'existence dans nos conventions
économiques alors historiquement bien
fonctionné historiquement voilà comment
ça se présente
voilà le pib reconstitué depuis l'an
zéro alors la reconstitution du pib en 1
0 c'est comme la population humaine en
moins 10000 1 ce moment la ligne c est
moins efficace qu'aujourd'hui mais enfin
on est quand même capable en ordre de
grandeur de faire des reconstitutions
vous avez ici à quoi ressemble le pib
mondial reconstitué depuis la naissance
de monsieur jésus christ alors ce que
vous voyez c'est que pendant très
longtemps
en fait la production économique de
l'humanité n'a quasiment pas varié tout
simplement parce que la population n'a
quasiment pas varié où elle variait très
peu et que par ailleurs il y avait des
pestes des machins et c est par ailleurs
la productivité par personne ne variait
pas puisqu'on n'avait pas d'auxiliaire
supplémentaires à s'adjoindre d'accord
on n'avait que notre puissance
musculaire et nos esclaves en rythmant
taux constants et nos animaux de trait
en taux constants donc ça varie pas
alors ça résout le problème des
élections mais c'est ce que je vous ai
mis là parce que il n'y a pas besoin de
promettre la croissance n'est pas de
croissance mais vous noterez aussi vous
qui allez faire des études qui sont
associés à cette affaire
vous n'avez pas non plus de démocratie
les seules démocraties en titre que vous
trouvez sont des démocraties qui ont
reproduit le système esclavagiste que
nous avons aujourd'hui avec nos machines
c'est à dire l'as rome et la grèce
antique où vous aviez une poignée de
citoyens libres assis sur une armée
d'esclaves
parce que pendant que les mecs faisait
leurs orgies et discuter de l'avenir de
la cité il y avait des millions
d'esclaves autour de rome qui bossait
pour eux pour leur faire leur nourriture
donc la démocratie n'était pas quelque
chose qui concerne l ensemble de la
population ça concernait une minorité de
nantis qui était assise sur une majorité
d'à servi et bien c'est exactement le
système que nous avons reproduit
aujourd'hui avec les machines
nous sommes une minorité quelques
milliards d'individus de nantis sur une
majorité et quelques milliers de
milliards d'individus de machines en
sorte que les machines gueule pas mais
sinon c'est exact la morale me vois rien
à y redire
enfin sauf pour les conséquences futures
mais donc voilà voilà exactement le
système qu'on a reproduit donc pas de
croissance
retenez bien ce que je vais vous dire
c'est pas complètement sûr on garde la
démocratie la démocratie comme vous
pouvez le constater aujourd'hui c'est
l'art de promettre plus à tout le monde
dans un monde sans croissance est
arithmétiquement impossible donc si je
promets plus à ce jeune homme en orange
au milieu de la salle par construction
je promets - à cette jeune femme en
rouge là bas c'est par construction
encore dans un monde sans croissance est
comme ça donc conserver la démocratie
dans un monde sans croissance ici il
existe bien les deux
dans un monde sans croissance vous
n'arrivez pas à gérer un système
les arbitrages vont devenir
considérablement plus violent
considérablement plus vieux donc on a
intérêt à bien les faire jusqu'en 1850
c'est à dire la révolution industrielle
voyez il ya une croissance m'enfin faut
la regarder avec une loupe la preuve le
premier pays où ça décolle vraiment
c'est l'angleterre parce que
l'angleterre commence à taper dans son
charbon et le charbon c'est les machines
et puis arrive le début des combustibles
fossiles est alors la cera l'oubli et
vous avez l'invention par les
économistes de la croissance
structurelle le long terme
quelle bonne blague quelle bonne blague
ça existe évidemment par la croissance
structurelle de long terme
tous les systèmes physiques finissent
par revenir à l'équilibré quand ils sont
hors d'équilibré donc la croissance
structurelle de long terme ça n'existe
pas pour le moment nous avons une phase
transitoire de l'humanité un siècle et
demi ses cours au regard des temps
géologiques
avec de la croissance vous finirez votre
vie dans un monde sans croissance
même moi n'existe pas la croissance
structurelle
à court terme ça marche bien parce que à
court terme on n'a pas prévu sur
l'énergie à la voilà le meilleur modèle
macroéconomique que j'ai trouvé à ce
jour s'appelle une droite bas droite
elle vous dit regarde combien d'énergie
tu utilises sur terre c'est à dire
combien de machines tu met en mouvement
et moi je te dirai quel est le pib
mondial
ça marche extrêmement bien alors j'ai
pas le temps ce matin mais j'ai quelques
articles disponibles sur mon site sur
lequel je fais des monographies sur
certains pays et j'en ai fait une sur
l'italie il ya un an
l'italie est un cas d'école où cette
courbure à rebrousse chemin
à partir de 2006 il ya moins d'énergie
qui rentre dans le pays parce que
l'italie était un pays très dépendants
du pétrole et le pit conventionnelle
c'est 2008 donc l'italie voit son
approvisionnement en pétrole se casser
la gueule pas parce qu'elle l'a choisi
parce qu'elle me suffit c'est exactement
la même chose pour la grèce et pour le
portugal et pour l'espagne soit dit en
passant est à ce moment le pib italien
rebroussent chemin quoi que puisse
penser d'électeurs italiens encore
quoique puissent penser les lecteurs
italiens et c'est exactement ce qui nous
pend au nez dans tout le reste de
l'europe
exactement ce qui nous pend au nez dans
tout le reste de l'europe alors cet
asservissement il marche non seulement
en valeur absolue mais en variation ici
vous avez la variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans le
monde envers et la variation du pib
mondial en bleu ou avec sa marche
extrêmement bien c'est un très bon
asservissement parce que c'est les
machines qu'ils produisent
j'insiste et même dans les services
s'est des machines qui produisent dans
un service de transport vous avez des
grosses machines la sncf c'est le
premier consommateur d'électricité de
france dans les services dits à la
personne vous avez de l'énergie vous
n'allez pas chez la personne sans une
voiture voulu amener passent et
repassent en des usines pour produire
les repas les mettre sous plastique etc
et faire comme je lé vu l'autre jour là
des oeufs au plat sous plastique donc
vous donc aucun service ne fonctionne
sans des machines aucun aucun aucun vous
allez au restaurant c'est un service il
ya des machines partout il ya des
machines qui s'appelle des camions qui
ont emmené la nourriture il ya des
machines qui s'appelle les tracteurs qui
l'ont produite il ya des machines qui
s'appelle les cuisines qui voulait
qu'ils voulaient chauffe qui voulaient
etc
vous avez des machines s'appelle des
hachoirs qui
et des machines partout partout partout
partout et comme l'essentiel de cette
énergie et fossiles voici le drame des
négociations climat c'est que pib ou co2
faut choisir
je répète non pib ou co2 faut choisir si
vous voulez plus de pib vous aurez plus
de co2 pendant que ça passe
donc ça passe pib au co2 faut choisir
qui a déjà entendu à part quelques
farfelus comme la mif cochet que j'adore
vous vous dire pib ou co2 il va falloir
choisir
quand on parle de la lutte contre le
changement climatique n'ont donc dans
les discours politiques non compris
je fais partie d'une instance qui
s'appelle le haut conseil pour le climat
on a eu un exposé je peux vous dire que
c'est pas confidentielles ces publics le
document on a eu un exposé de la
stratégie nationale bas carbone
le directeur général de l'énergie et du
climat brave polytechnicien comme moi a
quand même eu le culot de nous dire
enfin il a pas eu le culot c'est une
instruction ministérielle ce qui est un
des drames de la démocratie moderne soit
dit en passant c'est la dichotomie entre
le politique et l expertise a eu le
drame a eu le culot de nous dire le la
stratégie nationale bas carbone
c'est-à-dire la neutralité en france
augmentera le pib je répète alors
pourquoi il dit ça il me dit ça parce
qu'il utilise un modèle économique qui
inverse les liens de causalité c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure dans
tous les modèles économiques vous avez
de pib qui est exogène dire que le pib
c'est une variable d'entrée donc ils
augmentent ce que toute façon il va
augmenter sinon on a un problème avec
les retraites et dans tous les modèles
économiques quand vous rajoutez des
investissements ça vous foutez des
éoliennes partout ça vous augmente le
pib mécaniquement un les modèles sont
souvent keynésien c'est à dire que vous
augmentez les investissements il vous
augmente le pib donc vous partez d'un
pib qui augmentent de toute façon parce
que c'est un postulat de départ vous
rajoutez des investissements il augmente
encore plus et on m'explique que la
neutralité va augmenter le pib
évidemment que non la neutralité qui est
physiquement possible
c'est une énorme contraction du pib ça
veut pas dire qu'elle n'est pas
souhaitable vous allez voir après les
petits désagréments qui nous attend avec
le changement climatique
mais j'insiste ça ne se fera pas à pib
croissant c'est physiquement impossible
parce que justement ça fait deux siècles
trois siècles qu'on fait l'exact inverse
qu on augmente l'énergie en tapant dans
les docks qui sont supérieures aux
énergies renouvelables
donc l'histoire que je vous ai raconté
c'est ça on a des stocks de pétrole sous
terre c'est gratuit et des stocks de
charbon et les stocks de gaz
on a aussi des stocks de minerai etc
tout ça est gratuit alors utiliser du
pétrole c'est le brûler le brûler ses
l'oxydé l'oxydé c'est une réaction
chimique exothermique qui vous fait du
co2 c'est inexorable
alors vous ne savez pas oxydée du
carbone autrement qu'en faisant du co2
et ça ça ne changera pas dit si à votre
mort et ça ça vous permet de mettre en
oeuvre des machines qui transforme tout
le reste pour faire tous les produits
qu'on a sous la main cette abondance de
produits et cette formidable
augmentation de la productivité du
travail parce que la productivité du
travail x 100 c'est pas que chacun
d'entre vous est devenu shiva avec 100
paires de bras et sans paire de jambes
sauf erreur de ma part comme votre code
génétique et même qui a deux siècles
votre nombre de bras et de jambes et
aussi le même qui a deux siècles
d'accord vous avez si j'étais compté
jusqu'à 2 de bras et de jambes chacun et
chacune fera pas bouger
donc ce qui la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes plus productifs c'est pas con à
100 paires de bras et sans paire de
jambes c'est qu'on a des machines qui
travaillent pour nous sauf que
dénominateur est resté le même
au lieu de mettre sommes plus machine on
a laissé au dénominateur sommes
effectivement le produit au numérateur
augmente grâce aux machines ou le
dominateur on garde la même chose
la productivité au monde c'est juste une
affaire conventionnel on aurait pu
prendre un autre exemple enfin autre
indicateur on aurait fallu augmenter
donc grâce à cette formidable entre
guillemets augmentation de la
productivité ce qui veut dire qu'en fait
les machines dossier de place ça nous a
libérés plein de contraintes qu'on avait
avant d'abord on a pu habiter à un
endroit qui était loin des ressources
puisqu'on peut les transporter donc on
peut habiter en ville par exemple et
continue à bénéficier des ressources de
la campagne mange on s'habille on a des
pierres pour construire etc tout ça ne
pose aucun problème puisque l'énergie
sans charge les machines s'en charge
pour nous on a pu libérer du temps pour
faire des études à sciences po alix et
des tas de choses absolument
indispensable comme l'intelligence
artificielle dans les services bancaires
essentiel ce genre de truc ça mérite
beaucoup plus d'argent
que la lutte contre le changement
climatique oui ça compte ça consomme
beaucoup plus d'argent que la lutte
contre le changement climatique
si vous demandez aujourd'hui à un chef
d'entreprise qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important pour vous la lutte contre le
changement climatique ou le digital
il va vous dire les deux sont également
importants alors après vous lui demandez
et qu'est ce qui est plus important chez
vous le budget informatique ou le budget
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique
je connais la réponse vous avez un
facteur 1000 entre les deux dans dix
mille donc aujourd'hui la l'intelligence
artificielle dans les services bancaires
c'est quand même vachement plus
important que la lutte contre le
changement climatique
donc la productivité du travail qui
augmente permet de libérer des
contraintes libéré du tap ton libre et
ce temps libre puisqu'on travaille plus
les machines le foin de place ça s'est
investi dans 35 heures par semaine six
semaines de congés payés pas de travail
le week-end des études longues et la
retraite tout ça c'est l'énergie
tout ça c'est l'énergie donc les
négociations sociales dans un monde en
contraction énergétique bon courage
ça va être un peu plus fort que les
négociations sociales dans un monde
d'abondance
je crois que ça francis bouygues qu'on
attribuait cette maxime qui est en
période de croissance n'y a pas de
mauvais manager joule confiant quand on
a des problèmes de riches
on s'en sort en période de croissance il
n'y a pas de mauvais manager c'est
absolument certain
et donc en période de croissance il
n'est pas non plus une mauvaise
politique distribué durable de sucettes
n'importe quel crétin y arrive c'est
assez facile par contre distribuer un
défaut de sucettes ça je peux vous dire
que c'est autrement plus coton et
malheureusement c'est le monde qui vous
a tant qui m'a tant aussi du reste alors
ce cette production croissante
voilà on lui donna une contrepartie
économique qui s'appelle le pib est donc
il ya deux facteurs limitants au moins
cette affaire là qu'ils sont sains que
vous connaissez très bien qu'ils aient
ça provoque un changement climatique
cette affaire-là est-ce que ça va pas
finir par être un peu désagréable c'est
exercer d'expérience et un deuxième
facteur limitant dont les journaux
français ne parle quasiment jamais qui
est le facteur limitant à l'amont à
savoir est-ce que j'ai assez d'énergie
qui rentre dans le système pour lui
permettre de continuer à croître alors
pourquoi est ce que les médias français
ne parlent jamais du deuxième problème
tout simplement parce que pour le
premier problème vous avez de la science
en libre accès et des militants qui
milite au
un journal il reflète des communiqués de
presse
encore un journaliste ne se lève pas le
matin en disant tiens je vais faire une
monographie sur les ressources moyennes
des étudiants à sciences po il reçoit un
communiqué de presse de science po
disant cocorico les ressources moyennes
des étudiants à sciences po ont baissé
de 3% ça prouve bien que l'on se
démocratise et là à ce moment il va
aller regarder ce qui se passe mais
jamais il va lui devenir l'idée tout
seul de faire ça jamais jamais jamais
donc tout ce que vous voyez dans le
journal j'ai dis bien absolument tout ce
que vous voyez dans le journal vous avez
un truc qui en est à l'origine qui
s'appelle une dépêche est à l'origine de
la dépêche vous avez un communiqué de
presse la fp
c'est un système entrant c'est une gare
de triage et un système entrants et
c'est bien pour ça qu'il a des services
comme partout si les journalistes
savaient tout seul ce qu'il faut aller
regarder les services comme ne servirait
à rien ça serait pas la peine d'essayer
de les orienter dans ce qu'ils vont
raconter en leur envoyant des
informations
puisqu'ils savent déjà ce dont il faut
parler d'accord et comme le contrôle
budgétaire dans les entreprises est un
truc bien fait en général
eh bien on supprimerait ces gens qui ne
servent à rien puisque ça sert
absolument pas à faire en sorte que la
presse parle de ceci ou de cela donc la
presse ne parle de quelque chose que
parce qu'il ya eu une information
empreinte
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus donc du
coup on vous parle pas des problèmes sur
lesquels n'y a pas d'informations
entrantes or qui en france agite en dix
ans on a peut-être un problème déjà
d'approvisionnement énergétique à peu
près personne il ya trois clans pas dans
mon genre
oui c'est ça mathieu aux ados qui
travaillent avec moi plus mois +3
clampins dans mon genre je peux vous
dire qu'on ne pèsent rien face aux gens
qui s'agitent sur d'autres problèmes
donc le parce que peser quelque chose ça
veut dire faire l'ouverture du 20 heures
de tf1 c'est ça que ça veut dire
donc le
outre en ce donc le problème
hamon sur le l'énergie on ne le voit pas
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'il
n'ya pas de porter d'intérêt et ensuite
parce qu'on est obnubilé par les prix et
donc on pense que la rareté se reflète
par le prix et je vais vous montrer dans
pas longtemps que c'est faux on peut
manquer de quelque chose et pourtant son
prix nominal n'augmente pas mais j'y
vais alors le je vais commencer par la
partie amont c'est à dire est ce qu'on
va avoir de l'énergie a dit à mme
aeternam alors il se trouve que la
réponse est non c'est assez facile à
comprendre
il faut de 50 à 300 millions d'années
pour former des combustibles fossiles 50
à 350 à 400 millions d'années ce qui
veut dire qu échelle de temps qui vous
intéresse c'est à dire la soirée de la
fin de la semaine
pardon c'est à dire quelques siècles eh
bien on peut considérer que le stock de
combustible fossile qui a sous terre il
est donnée une fois pour toutes d'accord
on a un héritage mère nature nous a
légué cet héritage ne change pas il faut
aussi une certaine quantité on la
connaît pas bien au départ mais il y en
a pas plus que ça à partir du moment où
vous tapez dans un stock de départ qui
est donnée une fois pour toutes les
mathématiques vous interdisent que vous
puissiez avoir une production
indéfiniment croissante est d'accord
sinon ça veut dire que le stock est
infinie c'est même interdit d'avoir une
production indéfiniment constante parce
que sinon le stock est toujours un fils
y tout ce que vous avez le droit d'avoir
c'est une production qui part de zéro au
moins l'infini qui finit à 0 à +
l'infini et qui passe par un maximum
entre les deux c'est un théorème de
match c'est même encore le démontrer
alors ce que je vous dis ça vaut pour le
pétrole mais ça vaut pour le gaz ça vaut
pour le minerai de cuivre ça vaut pour
le minerai de pour le minerai
d'aluminium ça vaut pour le tungstène le
cobalt le nickel le zirconium le lithium
le just nemisz et ça vaut pour n'importe
quelle ressource dont le stock de départ
sous terre est disponible en quantité
donnée une fois pour toute et donc pour
toutes ces ressources là sur lesquelles
notre économie et à 6
vous aurez quelque chose qui s'appelle
le pic donc le pic c'est pas une théorie
fumeuse c'est un théorème de maths et
les théorèmes comme vous le savez sont
toujours valables dans leur domaine de
validité n'y a pas d'exception sinon
c'est pas un théorème
très facile de démontrer qu'un truc est
pas vrai en maths vous le savez il
suffit de montrer qu'il ya un cas de
figure où c'est pas vrai donc un
théorème c'est que c'est toujours vrai
il n'y a pas d'exception c'est pas une
fois vrai il faut toujours et là c'est
pareil
aucun rêve que je peux avoir que vous
pouvez avoir que n'importe qui peut
avoir pour l'avenir ne peut exister s'il
doit violer un théorème de maths c'est
juste pas possible
alors en ce qui concerne le pétrole se
pique on s'en rapproche
en fait on a déjà passé pour une partie
du pétrole dans le monde et qu'on s'en
rapproche on peut le voir en regardant
non pas la production mais la variation
de la production de pétrole sur un
siècle et demi eh bien vous voyez que
cette variation le pétrole augmentait de
15 % par an il ya un siècle et demi il
augmentait de 10 % par an avec des
moyens plus sophistiqués soit dit en
passant
après il augmentait de 5 % par an il ya
quelques dizaines d'années avec des
moyens encore plus sophistiquées et
aujourd'hui avec le shale oil il
n'augmente plus que d'un peu plus de 0 %
par an
donc en fait la technique c'est pas un
moyen d'augmenter la production plus
vite c'est une réponse au fait qu'on a
des contraintes sur ce qui précède c'est
bien comme ça qu'il faut le voir le ch
et le gaz c'est un truc est connu depuis
deux siècles
le premier éclairage municipal qui a eu
dans le monde au gaz au gaz dits de
ville a été fait enfin au gaz naturel
par don a été fait avec du shale gas à
fredonia sur la côte est des états unis
à deux siècles donc le ch et le gaz
c'est un truc est connue depuis très
longtemps et en fait on y revient parce
que les autres types de ressources
commence à poser problème
c'est bien dans ce sens là que ça se
passe et pas dans le sens inverse l'
agence internationale de l'énergie alors
la presse a totalement passée ça sous
silence totalement a sorti en décembre
un rapport disant le pour la partie
conventionnelle du pétrole sthers qui
n'est pas celle oeil le pétrole de
roche-mère et ce qui n'est pas les
sables bitumineux du canada
tout le reste a passé son pic en 2008 et
depuis ça décline qui en a entendu
parler de ce truc là à part les lecteurs
deux anneaux mais bon je peux vous dire
que c'est autrement plus importants pour
votre avenir qu'une bonne partie des
choses dont vous avez entendu parler
dans la presse sinon la quasi totalité
de ceux dont vous avez entendu parler
dans la presse ça ça veut dire que notre
costume d'iron man il va commencer à
rétrécir
c'est ça que ça veut dire
personne n'en a parlé
alors voilà où on est en gros sur
l'extraction mondiale de pétrole
sachant que dans le pétrole il ya aussi
le non conventionnel et donc ça veut
dire que les pétroliers que je connais
disent depuis longtemps
le sommet de la production mondiale de
pétrole tous confondus y compris que le
shale oil a et c c'est 2020 a plus ou
moins cinq ans et plus ou moins 5
millions de barils/jour
voilà donc 2020 c'est l'année prochaine
je dis bien plus ou moins cinq ans
ça veut dire qu'avant la fin de vos
études vraisemblablement et très
certainement avant que vous ayez mon âge
ça c'est absolument certain
eh bien vous verrez l'approvisionnement
mondial sachant que l'européen a déjà
commencé à baisser
l'approvisionnement mondial en pétrole
se contracter et à ce moment là vous
verrez de la crise de la dette dans tous
les sens
c'est sûr que c'est pas besoin d'eux
et alors cette quantité de pétrole qu'on
extrait du sol est également un très bon
indicateur avancé de l'économie
vous avez parce que le pétrole c'est les
transports et qui a pas eu une entité
économique qui fonctionne sans transport
vous avez ici deux variations en rouge
vous avez la variation de la quantité de
pétrole qui sort du sol donc il s'agit
pas du prix il s'agit de la quantité et
en bleu vous avez la variation du pib
par personne
ce que vous voyez c'est que depuis les
chocs pétroliers où on a appris à être
plus efficace sur le pétrole est bien la
variation de la production de pétrole
dans le monde
c'est l'indicateur avancé qui fonctionne
le mieux de la variation du pib par
personne dans le monde
ça marche extrêmement bien c'est dit
bien que c'est un indicateur avancé
parce que ce que vous pouvez voir sur ce
graphique que ça marche c'est que
chronologiquement vous voyez que la
variation de la courbe rouge a tendance
à légèrement précédé la variation de la
courbe bleue donc c'est pas le pétrole
est un truc qui s'achètent j'ai une
croissance qui vient de mars
j'ai plus d'argent et donc j'achète plus
de pétrole c'est le pétrole est un
facteur limitant de la production parce
qu'il faut des transports pour produire
et donc si j'ai moins ou plus de pétrole
je suis capable de plus ou moins
transporter et donc je suis capable
d'avoir une activité transformative donc
économiques plus ou moins importantes je
vais vous le redire encore autrement
notre système économique étant un
système de transformation
l'économiste peut lui coller d euros
mais le physicien pour lui coller des
kilowattheures ça marche aussi bien
donc le glas blague que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure en disant vous auriez pu payer
vos carottes à getty le water oui oui
vous pourriez parfaitement payer vos
carottes avec des kilowattheures vous
pourriez est alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est pas le prix qu'il faut regarder
pas parce qu'il ya pas d élasticité prix
volutes voient là une élasticité
regardez bien c'est une élasticité 6,6
et une élasticité
je vous assure c'est une élasticité si
si c'est quoi une élasticité c'est vous
savez à graphique dans lequel vous
mettez le volume d'un côté et le prix de
l'autre et votre propre vous dit s'il y
en a plus c'est moins cher et s'il y en
a moins c'est plus cher
oui on est d'accord c'est bien ça que
vous avez entendu donc une élasticité
c'est une courbe qui ressemble aux
autres est en pointillé la voilà alors
là je vous ai mis sur un siècle de 1920
à aujourd'hui
la quantité de pétrole disponible sur le
marché c'est en abscisses et le prix du
pétrole par baril c'est en ordonnée est
ce que vous voyez une élasticité parce
que quiconque me répond oui a besoin
d'aller chez afflelou non pardon voilà
une élasticité
alors évidemment c'est une blague il n'y
a pas d'électricité et il n'y en a pas
non pas parce que ça me plaît parce que
vous regardez cette courbe et il n'y a
pas d'électricité
l'élasticité de long terme prix volume
sur le pétrole et sur l'énergie en
général n'existe pas donc c'est pas la
peine de regarder les prix pour savoir
si ça sera rare demain ça ne marche pas
et en fait alors j'ai pas le temps de
vous faire la théorie aujourd'hui mais
vous pouvez très simplement expliqué il
faut juste trois minutes et chaleur
commence à tourner vous pouvez très
simplement expliquer pourquoi c'est
structurellement impossible que vous
ayez pas dé l'activité et les deux
indicateurs sont les suivants c'est que
pour avoir beaucoup de pétrole faut
aller chercher des pétroles compliqué
donc ça fait monter le prix du baril
sauf que si vous faites monter prix du
baril vous décourager la demande et donc
vous avez moins de demande et donc vous
allez chercher moins de pétrole
donc en fait un pétrole qui commence à
devenir contraint son prix est aussi ion
il est ni eau ni bas il signe donc la
contrainte pétrolière va pas rendre le
prix obaïda rendre volatils et c'est en
fait la seule implication vous pouvez
regarder voyez pendant longtemps ça a
été constant ces cartes elysées puis là
ça commence à faire n'importe quoi ces
volatiles et ça va devenir
relate il en fait un économiste qui
regarderait ça et théorise rsa d'une
manière tout à fait différente il irait
il ya deux régimes inélastique il ya un
régime dans lequel vous avez un volume
qui est indépendant d'un prix qui fixe
puis un régime dans lequel vous avez un
prix qui est indépendant d'un volume qui
est fixe et puis on recommence
voilà la première la meilleure
approximation qui vous trouverai il ya
deux régimes inélastique orthogonaux
tous que alors en europe où est ce qu'on
attendait sur l'énergie vous avez ici la
quantité de pétrole disponible en europe
la quantité de pétrole c'est à la fois
le pétrole qu'on produit nous mêmes
c'est la mer du nord que vous voyez en
rose là-dessus et c'est qu'à passer son
pic en 2000 et c'est le pétrole qu'on
importe dont vous voyez qu'il est passé
par un maximum historique au moment des
chocs pétroliers et un maximum
secondaire au moment du pic de
production du pétrole conventionnel dans
le monde c'est-à-dire 2006 en
l'occurrence et donc la quantité de
pétrole qui rentre en europe a perdu 14%
depuis 2006 qui en avait entendu parler
qui pense que il ya une autre raison au
fait que les émissions de co2 des
transports en europe et b c est ce que
c'est parce que on a des politiques
intelligentes
pas du tout on a des politiques
continuent être parfaitement comme on
vend de plus en plus de suv on continue
à faire des autoroutes que des aéroports
on va mettre une nouvelle piste à roissy
dont on a du politique qui continue à
être parfaitement conne juste on émet
moins de co2 parce que il ya moins de
pétrole a cramé point barre point barre
d'accord par contre ça fait des gens qui
commencent à être privé de pétrole ça
s'appelle les gilet jaune et il trouve
pas ça drôle
et comme on n'avait pas vu le coup venir
on n'a rien prévu et on n'a pas vu le
coup venir tout simplement parce qu'on
s'est pas intéressée à la question c'est
pas parce que le coup était pas
prévisible on consomme du gaz en europe
alors le gaz est une énergie qui
voyagent moins bien que le pétrole le
pétrole vous avez deux tiers du pétrole
dans le monde qui passe une frontière
entre production et consommation
donc c'est une énergie qui se transporte
très très bien parce que ces liquides à
pression et température ambiante
donc les coûts de transbordement d'un
réservoir à un autre et des coûts de
transport sur un truc qui s'appelle en
bateau ça vaut rien ça vaut rien en
termes énergétiques savons pas rien en
terme économique ça vaut rien en terme
énergétique
donc vous pouvez très facilement en
consommer à un bout de la terre du
pétrole qui a été produit à l'autre ça
ne pose aucun problème
le gaz et gazeux nous dit dictionnaire
et il est donc mille fois moins denses
énergétiquement par unité de volume que
le pétrole donc le transport du gaz
c'est physiquement beaucoup plus
compliqué et vous n'avez que deux
manières simples de transporter le gaz
ou bien vous faites un tuyau mais le
tuyau il ya un producteur et un
consommateur nombre il faut être sûr de
se mettre d'accord pendant longtemps
parce que vous changez pas le tuyau
aussi le producteur se fâche avec le
consommateur
donc vous avez des contrats de long
terme et ça prend du temps de construire
un gazoduc beaucoup plus de temps que de
construire un pétrolier et surtout de le
détourner sur terre sur mer ou bien vous
faites du gaz liquéfié et c'est encore
plus compliqué j'ai pas le temps de
rentrer dans les détails ce qui veut
dire que en europe
quand la mer du nord est passé par son
pic de production en 2005 qui en avait
entendu parler personnes et biens
l'approvisionnement gazier européen est
passé par un pic
donc même les antinucléaires qui rêve de
remplacer le nucléaire par du gaz ils ne
remplaceront pas par du gaz aura pas le
gaz
parce que c'est compliqué de substituer
une production domestique par des
importations vous allez me dire qu'à
faire des trous en terre en france et en
europe très bien admettons qu'on ait
envie de faire des trous comme les
américains j'ai fait un petit calcul
d'ordre de grandeur
voilà ce qu'on arrive à sortir au max
donc il ya moins de pétrole
donc il ya moins de gaz il ya aussi
moins de charbon rien à voir avec le
climat
ça fait deux siècles comptable dans nos
mines en
en europe on a fermé la dernière mine
française sauf erreur de ma part dans
les années 90 dans ces eaux là
donc quand j'étais jeune y avait un
machin qui s'appelle charbonnages de
france que vous n'avez pas connu dont le
dernier patron a été chargé de fermer la
dernière mine puis de liquider la boîte
très sympathiques comme job est ce que
vous voyez là c'est que la production de
charbon en europe a été divisée par
quasiment 4 depuis les années 80 rien à
voir avec le climat en 1991 se
contrefoutait du problème climatique
ça a juste à voir avec le fait que quand
vous tapez dans vos mines débats il y en
a de moins en moins et un moment il ya
de moins en moins comme aurait dit
coluche et vous voyez également que les
importations de charbon c'est un terme
qui en valeur absolue et quasiment
constant c'est à dire que vous ne
compense est pas un déclin national par
des importations un pour un et pourquoi
vous ne le faites pas parce que le
charbon étain pondéreux et que la chaîne
logistique du charbon est une horreur
absolue
vous êtes obligés de faire des terminaux
portuaires dédié des indes et des
entrepôts qui sont monstrueux dédiées
etc
pour vous donner un exemple la centrale
à charbon allemandes de ne rate si ma
mémoire est bonne
qui est une centrale qui fait 4
gigawatts électrique donc c'est
équivalent à une centrale française qui
aurait quatre réacteurs de 900 enfants
de 2000 mégawatts
on va dire elle vous bouffe 50 mille
tonnes de charbon par jour 50 mille
tonnes de charbon par jour elle vous
évacue dix mille tonnes de cendres par
jour donc cette centrale là ça vous
donne une idée des quantités des masses
qu'il faut manipuler pour gérer du
charbon et donc quand vous avez de moins
en moins de charbon dans un pays vous
n'utilisez pas les importations pour
compenser parce que logistiquement c'est
indéniable et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le charbon pour produire de
l'électricité
vous en avez moins de 10% dans le monde
qui passe une frontière entre production
et consommation
donc je vais vous le dire encore
autrement le charbon est une énergie
domestique il faut savoir qu'il ya huit
pays dans le monde qui possède 90 % de
la ressource et donc sévi pays
détiennent une part essentielle de la
solution aux problèmes climatiques et
ses huit pays sont dans l'ordre
ça change un peu chaque année la chine
les etats unis la russie
c'est pas dans leur exactement c'est là
que les états unis d'abord les premières
réserves au monde la chine la russie
l'australie le kazakhstan l'afrique du
sud l'allemagne
là je suis à cet élan
ces huit pays la tienne une bande partie
du sort climatique de la planète entre
leurs mains parce que j'insiste le
charbon c'est chez eux que ça se passe
et ça sort pas de chez eux parce que le
charbon est une énergie domestique
ce qui m'a poussé à écrire cette petite
provocation n'ya pas longtemps qui est
qu'au lieu de se gargariser demande des
mirages alain on ferait mieux de se
gargariser de leur vendre des centrales
nucléaires pour remplacer leurs
centrales à charbon à mon avis la paix
dans le monde s'en porterait beaucoup
mieux alors voilà maintenant à quoi
ressemble le l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen par personne je
voulais me par personne depuis 1965
ce que vous voyez c'est que ça augmente
avec les énergies qui s'empilent
jusqu'au choc pétrolier et aux chocs
pétroliers ça se stabilise
c'est à dire que ça se met à rester
constant de quand datent les problèmes
de chômage en occident du moment où ça
se stabilise
de quand date le début de l'endettement
public du moment où ça se stabilise
pourquoi parce que au moment où ça se
stabilise la quantité de machines par
personne ne peut plus augmenter
modulo l'efficacité énergétique qui va
pas très vite donc la production par
personne ne peut plus augmenter
modulo l'efficacité énergétique qui va
pas très vite et on a avant bâti un
système de redistribution ce qu'on
appelle l'état providence dans tous les
pays occidentaux où on a de manière
mécanique la redistribution qui elle
augmente chaque année
un rythme que la production n'est plus
capable de suivre et là vous avez deux
termes d'ajustement qui sont les mêmes
dans toutes les économies occidentales
le chômage la dette et donc ces deux
termes d'ajustement apparaissent dans
tous les pays le chômage la dette
vous en avez un troisième qui est payé
les gens avec un lance pierres donc en
france ou en afrique
c'est un terme qui est peu mis en oeuvre
alors on a fini par le mettre en oeuvre
avec les emplois jeunes le temps partiel
machin etc mais
historiquement on ne faisait pas et dans
les pays dans lesquels n'y a pas de smic
et on voit arriver ce qu'on appelle les
oies requis pour c'est à dire les gens
qui bossent qui sont pas dans les
statistiques du chômage et qui pour
autant s'en sortent pas et qui cumule
deux jobs et qui machin etc sont payés
qu'à lens pierre et distribuer le lait
le matin les journaux l'après midi yves
ravot des les chaussettes entre 2 voilà
donc on n'a pas de deux et dans tous les
pays occidentaux c'est pareil donc
l'incurie des politiques français à
résoudre le problème de la dette et le
chômage en fait c'est l'incurie de
toutes les démocraties occidentales a
cessé l'état providence au moment où la
productivité du travail s'arrête
d'augmenter à la bonne vitesse et c'est
vrai dans tous les pays occidentaux à
des degrés divers
et puis arrive le deuxième temps de
cette affaire donc sarkozy n'a pas dit
que des bêtes n'a pas dit que des choses
vraies mais il en a dit une qui était
absolument juste qui était que 2007
était la plus grave crise économique
qu'on ait connues depuis 1929
en fait c'est même pire que ça 2007
c'est pas une crise c'est le début d'une
nouvelle mutation
cette nouvelle mutation c'est la baisse
de l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne alors qui a connu un petit
rebond à partir de 2014 parce que 2014
c'est l'explosion fin 2013 2014 c'est
l'explosion du shale oil aux états unis
qui réapprovisionnent le marché mondial
en pétrole pendant quelques années ça
continue à avoir lieu et donkey
réapprovisionnent le parc de machines
mondiale qui permet de produire donc
l'économie
voilà retrouve une petite bouffée
d'oxygène mais ça ça va durer qu'un
temps parce que le che l'oeil ça va pas
augmenter indéfiniment
donc dès que le celle aux etats unis va
commencer à donner des signes
d'essouflement
ce truc-là repartir à la baisse et on
aura de nouveau une crise économique
significative en europe donc surveillez
bien la production de shell aux états
unis c'est l'indicateur avancé de ce qui
va se passer où je vais fichiers de
finance pas trop longtemps et après il y
aura plein de questions
c'est l'indicateur avancé de 2 de la
façon dont l'économie va se comporter
dans les démocraties occidentales dans
les années qui suivront il vous voyez
que les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
en violet là ne sont toujours pas en
mesure de compenser le nucléaire au rap
celui qui est juste en dessous plus de
gaz plus le pétrole plus le charbon qui
sont également juste en dessous sans
compter petite parenthèse qu'aujourd'hui
la baisse de coûts qu'on a sur les
énergies d'énergies là
sont issus de la productivité des
énergies fossiles le jour où vous n'avez
plus que des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires pour faire pour aller chercher
le cuivre dans les mines pour
transporter les éléments intermédiaires
pour faire fonctionner la grue qui érige
l'éolienne etc on en reparlera du coût
de l'éolien aujourd'hui c'est bien parce
que j'ai moins 1,5 bouteille de whisky
qui me permet de faire mon jus d'orange
que mon jus d'orange et pas cher mais le
jour où j'ai plus le whisky pour faire
le jus d'orange
on en reparlera du prix du jus d'orange
à l'époque où nous n'avions que des
énergies renouvelables c'est à dire des
moulins et des bateaux à voile donc si
je reviens au moulin et aux bateaux à
voile pour faire d'autres moulins c'est
à dire des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires
on en reparlera du prix 1 pour
aujourd'hui fait attention à cette
illusion d'optique qui est que ce qu'on
a coutume d'appeler des solutions c'est
aussi vrai pour les batteries des
voitures électriques etc hérite de la
formidable productivité que nous avons
grâce aux énergies fossiles
le système est asservi c'est systémique
personnes à mon sens aujourd'hui il a
fait le moindre calcul sur comment
évolue ce prix dans un monde dans lequel
il n'y a plus que des énergies
renouvelables pour assurer la production
j'ai jamais vu un calcul là dessus alors
ce que je viens de vous dire se traduit
voilà dans le pib par personne en europe
donc vous avez les trente glorieuses
pendant lequel ça augmente de aller 5 6%
par personne et par an la cera lovely
comme chez gotlib
ensuite vous avez les trente piteuses
vous n'avez plus d'augmentation du de
l'énergie par personne mais vous avez
deux termes qui vont faire augmenter le
pib
1 vous avez le
développement des services qui
permettent de mieux exploiter les flux
industriels sous jacent ils permettent
pas de s'en passer
ils permettent de mieux les exploiter et
de vous avez l'inflation des actifs
il se trouve que l'inflation des actifs
n'est pas supprimée dans le calcul du
pib
ces comptes et au nominal et donc ça
vous créez un pib virtuel un exemple
très simple c'est la hausse du prix de
l'immobilier dans paris que vous devez
bien constaté et bien si un mètre carré
vaut deux fois plus cher aujourd'hui
qu'il ya dix ans vous avez toujours
qu'un mètre carré et physiquement mais
vous avez une augmentation du pib parce
que pour l'acheter vous devez plus vous
endettez ans la production de crédits et
dans le pib
si vous l'achetez à une agence vous avez
des commissions d'agent ce qui augmente
et ça c'est dans le pib et les droits de
mutation vous allez payer vont doubler
et ça c'est aussi dans le pib et vous
avez toujours qu'un seul mètre carré à
l'arrivée mais vous avez plus de pib
donc l'inflation des actifs c'est
quelque chose qui crée du pib
mécaniquement ce n'est pas vrai pour
l'inflation des chaussures mais par
contre c'est vrai pour l'inflation des
actifs et enfin arrive la période post
piqué vous voyez que on a deux gros
tentation vers le bas on a un rebond
vers le aujourd'hui qui est moins élevé
que tous ceux qui ont précédé et ça va
repartir vers le bas dans pas très
longtemps
et à ce moment vous demandez aux anglais
ce que vous êtes contents les anglais
vous dise non mais vous demander aux
italiens à ce que vous êtes contents et
ils élisent des populistes vous demander
enfin ce bazar partout pour la même
raison
pour la même raison parce que le gâteau
n'augmente plus et du coup les
phénomènes d'arbitrage deviennent des
phénomènes douloureux et par exemple si
on décide qu'en europe on à la libre
circulation des personnes et des
marchandises entre des gens de l'est
qu'ils aillent pas beaucoup et des gens
de l'ouest qu'il ya une beaucoup plus il
se passe ce qui se passe en ce moment
les industriels vont investir à l'est et
les plombiers passe à l'ouest
et si vous demandez aux salariés aux ex
plombier de l'ouest y trouve ça drôle
ils vous disent non et vous savez que
dans les référendums ça aussi c'est un
truc que vous apprendrez pendant vos
études j'imagine on répond beaucoup plus
à la personne qui pose la question qu'à
la question le grand piège du référendum
c'est celui-là il faut une civilisation
très adulte pour être capable de
répondre à la question n'est pas la
personne qui pose la question les
celui-ci arrive à peu près chez nous je
suis pas sûr que ce sera le cas
et là dessus nous avons un deuxième
problème alors non vous allez me dire le
problème réglé depuis 2015 et depuis
monsieur fabius qui brandit son grand
marteau du commissaire priseur à la coop
21 ans nous avons réglé le problème
climatique
alors voilà la façon dont je vois le
problème réglé
vous avez ici la concentration en co2
dans l'air depuis 1995 c'est à dire la
première conférence des parties de la
convention climat
donc vous voyez en 1995 la convention
climat est un grand succès puisque c'est
la première enfin la coop est un grand
succès c'est la première on a enfin une
convention climat qui s'applique et on
va enfin résoudre le problème après on a
eu copenhague qui était auto qui est un
succès à copenhague qui était en échec
paris qui est un grand succès et vous
voyez l'évolution des points alors moi
je vous pose une question quand vous
avez en physique une expérience dont
vous voyez que le résultat est
indépendant de la valeur d'une variable
vous en tirer comme conclusion que cette
variable n'intervient pas dans le
résultat de l'expérience donc j'en tire
une conclusion qui est que ce que la
presse dit sur une coop est indépendant
de ce qui se passe ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance ce que la presse dit sur
une coque copenhague j'y étais j'ai été
pendant les 15 jours je peux vous dire
que c'est tout sauf un échec par rapport
aux autres coop les deux degrés date de
copenhague c'est pas pareil que les deux
degrés ont été entérinés si à copenhague
et c'est parce que monsieur jadot et
consorts sont pavaner devant les caméras
en visant c'est un échec parce qu'il
était vexé comme des poudres pas avoir
été associée à la décision
c'est à peu près comme ça que ça s'est
passé que la presse a retenu que c'était
un échec mais ce n'était pas du tout un
échec
donc le enfin encore une fois
relativement aux autres
après ils sont tout d échec puisque ça
augmente tout ce que je vais vous
montrer à maintenant dans les cinq
minutes qui me restent parce qu'on fait
la grosse la grosse tête
les gros yeux
c'est quelques éléments je laisserai la
présentation d'abord il faut savoir que
l'effet de serre c'est un truc qui est
connu depuis deux siècles
donc c'est pas de la science qui date
d'hier en effet de serre c'est connu
depuis deux siècles
ça fait plus d'un siècle qu'on sait ce
qui se passe quand on fait de compte en
double de la quantité de co2 dans l'air
donc en gros on connaît très bien le
dossier scientifique depuis très
longtemps
les gens qui disent tous ça c'est des
conneries sont tous des imposteurs alors
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un imposteur dans
le dictionnaire
c'est quelqu'un qui revendique une
légitimité qu'il n'a pas qu'est-ce qu'il
faut avoir comme légitimité pour
revendiquer un avis sur le dossier
scientifique
il faut soi-même être chercheur et avoir
publié dans une revue scientifique à
comité de lecture un élément qui
invaliderait les ce qu'on trouverait
déjà dans le dossier c'est comme ça que
ça se passe dans la recherche ça fait
quatre siècles c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
il n'y a pas une personne pas un
argument avancé par les gens qui disent
c'est pas vrai qui correspond à cette
définition pas une pas un
donc c'est tous des imposteurs mis en
avant par les médias qui adore les
combats de coqs
c'est juste ça n'aurait compris que
j'aime beaucoup les médias mais c'est
exactement ça quand vous voyez le
système de l'intérieur c'est exactement
comme ça que ça que ça s'organise mhz
alors la cause du changement climatique
c'est pour partie la cause de
l'utilisation de l'énergie
c'est qu'on émet du co2 à cause du
pétrole du gaz du charbon on émet du co2
à cause de la déforestation coût des
forêts sont en sabre il en amazonie vous
le savez on est mais d'autres gaz à
effet de serre parce qu'un gaz à effet
de serre c'est juste à gaz qui
intercepte les infrarouges terrestre il
ya plusieurs gars qui correspondent à
cette définition
on aimait du méthane avec nos activités
agricoles et l'énergie fossile et enfin
ont été envoyés que tout ça croyez
embellie comme tout le reste est alors
retenez bien maintenant cet élément que
je vais vous donner le co2 est un oxyde
c'est une molécule qui est chimiquement
inerte une fois qu'il est dans l'air
corses est une molécule qui est
chimiquement inerte une fois dans l'air
donc il n'y a pas de mécanisme
d'épuration rapide du co2 de
l'atmosphère
si demain matin j'arrête les émissions
de co2
le surplus que nous avons déjà créé dans
un siècle il en restera à peu près la
moitié dans un millénaire il en restera
à peu près 20% dans dix mille ans il en
restera à peu près 10%
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est que le processus est
fondamentalement irréversible 1 c'est
pas il n'y a pas de bouton reset
et c'est pas comme dans game of thrones
si vous avez raté la troisième série
vous y revenez en replay là c'est pas
possible
vous n'avez aucune possibilité c'est
comme le vieillissement d'un organisme
vous n'avez aucune possibilité de
revenir en arrière
aucune dit autrement c'est une
expérience qu'on ne fera qu'une fois et
à cause de l'inertie du co2 dans l'air
si à un moment quelconque on considère
que le résultat de l'expérience nous
déplaît la seule certitude que nous
avons à ce moment là c'est que c'est
pire derrière
j'insiste la seule certitude que nous
avons à ce moment là c'est que c'est
pire derrière ce qui veut dire que c'est
des problèmes qui sont à gérer sur des
durées qui dépasse notre entendement et
qui dépasse à l'évidence un mandat
politique
donc il ya un drame fondamental dans la
démocratie est un système court termiste
comme vous le savez qui est de
réconcilier ce sujet là qui est un sujet
d'hyper long terme avec la volatilité
d'une démocratie qui est un système
hyper court terme
et soit dit en passant grâce à
l'abondance énergétique ça fait des
décennies qu'on raccourci les échéances
partout on avait des sociétés
patrimonial qui regardait quand même un
peu plus loin que le bout de leur nez
on a maintenant des sociétés cotées en
bourse ou en 2d s'excite parce que le
cours de bourse a varié en 24 heures
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout aucune espèce
d'importance si on voulait régler et qu
enfin des trucs à faire dans le monde
économique si on veut régler le problème
du changement climatique c'est de
supprimer la cotation en continu des
entreprises alors ça défrise rabot coup
certains d'entre vous qui veulent aller
bosser dans le compte
je sais pas où en gagner plein d'argent
mais c'est évident que ça fait partie
des trucs à faire très rapidement 5
degré de variation de la température
planétaire c'est pas un truc anodin
vous avez ici à quoi ressemblent les
écosystèmes européens si on ne supprime
pas pour faire autre chose aujourd'hui
vous avez ici à quoi ressemble l'europe
il ya dix mille ans il ya vingt mille
ans par dont il ya vingt mille ans
c'est-à-dire au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire
donc il fait beaucoup plus froid 1 c'est
en visite à leur envoyer que ça
ressemble à rien de ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas d'erasmus en
suède parce qu'à pas de suède
les scandinaves sont sous trois
kilomètres de glace donc l'acte m'a dit
vous oublier il n'y a pas non plus
d'erasmus à edimbourg connue pour son
climat chatoyant et ces écossais qui le
sont vraiment
et vous voyez qu'il n'ya pas non plus de
manches puisque l'océan a baissé de 120
mètres alors pouquoi l'océan a baissé
parce que pour faire cette énorme
glaciers qui assure la scandinavie et
son grand cousin qui assurent le canada
et le groenland et l'antarctique qui
augmentait de masse faut bien avoir pris
l'eau qu'est par l'eau vous l'avez prise
dans l'océan et donc le niveau de
l'océan a baissé vous voyez que les
écosystèmes qu'on utile qu'on trouve en
france ressemble à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui au nord de la sibérie et la
population humaine en france à cette
époque ne fait même pas la population de
la totalité des grandes écoles
françaises c'est dire et bien la
différence de température que vous avez
entre planétaire la différence moyenne
planétaire que vous avez entre paysages
de gauche et de paysages de droite c'est
juste 5 degrés de réchauffement
c'est juste ça en cinq mille ans alors
je vais pas passer les conséquences
parce que l'heure tourne mais je vais
quand même vous dire deux choses 1
l'expérience est tellement inédites
qu'il est illusoire de penser qu'on peut
imaginer toutes les conséquences
possibles avance cet impossible donc la
pensée sympathique qui consisterait à
dire qu aux médecins faites-moi
l'inventaire exhaustif de tout ce que je
risque avant que je commence un premier
mes fesses c'est une question qui n'a
pas de réponse
par contre quand vous voyez ça moi je
vais vous en donner une
ça sera la guerre partout c'est à dire
que le déplacement des conditions
multiséculaire dans lesquelles nous
avons bâti nos civilisations
il y aura beaucoup trop vite au surplus
dans un monde dans lequel notre capacité
de réaction c'est à dire l'énergie ira
en se contractant pour une partie
croissante de la population pour que
tout ça se gère dans la joie et la bonne
humeur
donc le monde qui ne s'occupe pas du
changement climatique
j'insiste j'ai deux enfants qui ont
votre âge ne suis pas en train de dire
faire juste pour me faire mousser
c'est un monde conflictuelle violents
dans lequel vous pouvez oublier les
promesses de croissance perpétuelle le
plus pour tout le monde
la paix est le seul problème qui est
savoir comment on fait revenir les
touristes japonais à paris vous assurer
qu'on aura d'autres chats à fouetter
donc lutter contre le changement
climatique s'est pas de mon point de vue
un truc sympathique à faire
en plus des comptes trimestriels qui
sont quand même vraiment l'urgence du
moment
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'ici on
ne le met pas au centre est en fait
lutter contre la contraction de
l'environnement au sens large
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'il faut faire
tenir 8 milliards de bons hommes sur une
planète qui fait toujours 13 mille
kilomètres de diamètre aujourd'hui comme
elle le faisait il ya trois siècles
ça va pas changer ça et avant qu'on vous
envoie tous sur mars en prenant un
billet chez elle mais ce qui va se
passer du temps je vais vous assurer que
son fournisseur de cocaïne et plus
fiable que ses plans pour déplacer
d'humanité donc le wii wheel est connu
pour ça donc le donc cette affaire de
changement climatique
j'insiste et d'une manière générale
faire revenir la contrainte physique
dans les plans pour l'avenir c'est ça le
message essentiel que je vais vous
délivrez c'est pas une coquetterie
c'est si on ne fait pas ça on est sûr
d'avoir n'importe quoi sauf ce qu'on
s'imagine pour l'avenir je vais
m'arrêter là parce que l'heure tourne
[Applaudissements]
parler fort sinon à moins que ce soit
enregistrée mais
est ce que ça fonctionne maintenant très
bien la question que je me pose c'est
est ce que dans un scénario de
transition il est possible aussi de
chercher de meilleures conditions de vie
en allant du côté de la sobriété de
questionner le besoin et puis ensuite de
l'efficacité énergétique est ce que on a
une sorte de salut de ce côté là merci
alors il en fait il faut renverser la
question ou plus exactement il faut
renverser des conditions aux limites
alors je vais vous donner un premier
exemple et ensuite j'irai aujourd'hui
dans la recherche économique
macroéconomiques
la seule question que les chercheurs se
pose c'est comment faire revenir la
croissance je pense que ça vaudrait le
coup qu'avec 5 % de nos impôts parce que
la recherche est essentiellement payé
par nos impôts il ya une petite partie
des gens qui se disent admettant
qu'elles ne reviennent pas c'est quoi la
meilleure optimisation du système
alors ça c'est une partie de la réponse
à votre question c'est à dire en fait
vous renverse la question on dit on
admet qu'on l'aura pas même pas où la
recherche ne leur a pas c'est quoi la
meilleure manière de s'organiser pour
que les gens soient le plus heureux
possible
c'est ce que les ingénieurs apple d'une
optimisation sous contrainte comme une
contrainte et oui moi je pense qu'il
faut alors le problème c'est que quand
on vous a dit pendant toute votre vie
plus vous courrez vite et mieux vous
vous portez c'est indicible de vous dire
maintenant on va vous expliquer que -
vous courrez vite et mieux vous vous
portez c'est très compliqué de passer
donc moi à mon âge par exemple secours
de moins en moins vite avec les ans donc
j'essaie de m'occuper d'autres choses
on me dit jean ce pas très grave au
secours de moins en moins vite il ya un
autre truc toit sur lequel je suis
finalement assez content de ce qui se
passe est donc tout bien pesé
[Musique]
et c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire qu'il faut arrêter de se
focaliser sur le pib il faut on peut
continuer à le comté de façon il est
indispensable c'est la base fiscale etc
faut juste arrêter de 2,2 d'incarner
tout le bonheur de l'humanité là dedans
d'accord je suis pas sûr que ça vaille
le coup de mesurer le bonheur autrement
qu'en demandant au genre est ce que vous
êtes content je suis assez triviale de
ce point de vue faut avoir des proxys
raconte ce dont je suis sûr c'est qu'il
faut être capable de proposer des
projets qui n'ont pas besoin de la
croissance pour que les gens se disent
tiens où et quand même j'ai envie alors
je vais reprendre les vacances puisque
vous étiez en vacances il ya pas
longtemps un certain nombre d'entre vous
pendant les vacances ont vu des
conditions matérielles d'existence
plutôt moins sympathique que celle que
vous avez pendant l'année par exemple si
vous êtes partis faire du camping
eh bien vous êtes moins bien logique
dans un appartement il ya les moustiques
qui rentre
la lumière du jour le matin vous
entendez voisin voisins afin de fêter
enfin bon bref le pourtant il ya des tas
de gens qui reviennent ravis de leurs
vacances en camping d'accord donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya moyen de moyenner
comme disait l'autre et qu'il ya des cas
de figure dans lesquels on peut très
bien vous dire je te donne un peu moins
d'ici un peu plus de là et à ce moment
il faut entraîner les gens sur des
projets on a réfléchi à l'avance sur
qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer où il ya
moins de pib mais plus d'autres choses
dont les gens accepteront et on organise
la vente entre guillemets sur le plus
d'autres choses en dix ans et je vais
vous aider accessoirement à vous
organiser
je vais vous donner un exemple si vous
diminuez les revenus des gens vous devez
corrélativement diminuer les loyers
comment est ce qu'on fait pour diminuer
les loyers faut faire dégonfler les
grandes villes donc vous voyez que un
des moyens de s'accommoder d'une baisse
du pib
c'est d'arrêter de concentrer tous le
développement dans paris et quelques
métropoles
il faut faire l'exact inverse à partir
de maintenant corps c'est la seule
condition à la campagne un certain
nombre de ressources peuvent être quasi
gratuite commencer par l'air que vous
respirez alors que les tokyoïtes ils ont
besoin d'avoir un distributeur oxygène
man donc vous vous êtes capable du coup
de vous accommoder d'une baisse de vos
revenus moi je connais des gens qui ont
fait ce choix de manière délibérée j'ai
pas l'impression qu'ils soient plus
malheureux voilà donc c'est il s'est
plutôt comme ça donc j'ai envie de dire
c'est aux corps intermédiaires qui
forgent la politique et qui forgent les
projets qu'ils soient dans la politique
ou chez les décideurs économiques ou
chez les académiques et c'est de penser
des plans qui s'accommode d'une baisse
de la croissance que vous ne vendrez
jamais en tant que tel parce que ça
c'est inaudible vous allez y passer
vingt ans avant que
on a 30 ans pour résoudre le problème
donc vous n'avez pas le temps d'accord
mais c'est bien comme ça qu'il faut s'y
prendre il faut aussi prendre en
proposant des trucs qui n'ont plus
besoin de la croissance
je vais large donc par exemple pablo
servi nier ce que vous pensez aussi de
la réactualisation pardon du rapport de
rome qui a été fait en 2002 si je me
trompe pas et en fait de manière
générale ma question c'est de savoir
quels sont vos conseils de lecture pour
que bah on continue à travailler sur la
question en cherchant les solutions et
en cherchant à vraiment comprendre
comment ça se passe comment ça va se
passer pour ba sensibiliser les gens au
fait d'accord alors qu'est ce que je
pense de la décroissance je viens de
répondre
en fait ce que je pense de pablo service
expert bosses ses pardons
c'est un beau gosse non il dit des
choses intéressantes
il n'est pas dans l'orgie de la solution
tableau mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ils proposent des angles sur la
façon de voilà ce que je pense de la
coloc zoologie c'est de se dire tout est
foutu ça ne mène nulle part
par contre de se dire je vais essayer
d'apprécier la hauteur de l'aller à
franchir sa semaine quelque part donc ça
m'amène à la dernière question qui est
qu'est ce qu'on peut lire pour continuer
à se documenter
alors ce que vous appelez le rapport du
club de rome
c'est le condensé d'un travail de
dynamique des systèmes que moi j'ai lu
il ya quelques années qui s'appelle the
limits groff donc dont je vous conseille
ardemment la lecture parce que c'est un
traité magistral sur la dynamique des
systèmes et qui théorisent la façon dont
l'économie physique se comportent et ça
a été fait par une demande de chercheurs
du mighty dont l'un est encore vivant
dennis meadows
j'ai même eu l'immense honneur de
préfacer le fauteuil update qui est
sorti en france il ya quelques années
effectivement donc j'ai croisé grand
bonhomme à cette occasion et ça explique
justement pourquoi l'économie ne peut
pas croître indéfiniment
voilà donc ça c'est une lecture sur
comment se présente le problème après la
lecture sur comment s'attaquer au
problème ça là j'ai envie de dire elle
et elle est compliquée je peux vous
proposer une lecture d'entrée alors
c'est pas une religion mais c'est un
travail qu'on a fait ou chic project on
a fait avant les élections
présidentielles et de rester un certain
emmanuel macron qui nous a dit que notre
travail et des formidables mais bon jeu
certains d'entre vous iront peut-être
bosser dans les cabinets ministériels où
ils répondront vos idées sont
formidables à tous les gens qui écrivent
donc je fais partie des jobs qu'on
trouve dans ce genre d'endroit ça ça
veut dire vous entendrez plus jamais
parler moi je vous précise donc le
le plan qu'on avait proposé avant les
dernières élections ça plaît dit
carbonneau europe et donc le site
internet qui va avec c'est dit
carbonneau rock tout attaché avec un z
évidemment puisque c'est en anglais avec
un seul lieu au milieu un point org et
vous verrez il ya neuf propositions qui
sont en fait des propositions de
maquereaux planning par filière alors là
je vais donner un ton très optimiste à
ce que je vais dire nous avons la chance
en france d'être le seul pays
communistes d'europe de l'ouest
nous sommes le seul pays communistes
d'europe de l'ouest
on veut que tout le monde soit égal on
veut que tout le monde ait la même chose
on égalitarisme sommes le seul pays
communistes d'europe de l'ouest
on s'est un peu oublié à cause des
économistes de boston dans l'économie de
marché mais c'est une connerie parce
qu'on a perdu ce qui faisait notre force
et il se trouve que le problème de long
terme que j'ai évoquées demande une
réponse de long terme et c'est un truc
qui s'appelle la planification en les
français sont très très bons à ce jeu là
du reste on a été des grands
exportateurs de planification on sait
planifier des grands réseaux ferrés qui
marche bien et les français pour pas
être content de la sncf allait voir à
l'étranger vous allez voir les
comprendre votre douleur
à chaque fois je prendrai en allemagne
est en retard vous avez une très grande
planification qui s'est faite sur le
réseau électrique ya que les français
pour pas être contente en réseau
électrique à doha les voir à l'étranger
vous allez comprendre
allez demander aux américains tient vous
avez des en ce qui concerne l'eau
potable en ce qui concerne les réseaux
de transport etc
les français ont été historiquement
quasiment les meilleurs au monde et les
plus proches de nous c'est les chinois
sont pas du tout les américains ces
chinois il se trouve que le problème la
demande une réponse à large échelle
donc on a un avantage concurrentiel
compétitif historique qui est de savoir
bien pensé les solutions à large échelle
donc il ya deux manières d'approcher les
solutions il ya dans son travail savoir
pensé et planifié mettre en oeuvre
derrière des solutions intelligentes à
large échelle mais ça suppose d'avoir
bien compris le problème si l'on tape à
côté et dans son action quotidienne
avoir compris qu'elle était les actes
reproductible parce qu'un vrai qu'ils
sont par terre vous occupez juste une
niche et puis après c'est en tant pis
pour les autres et tant mieux pour vous
avoir compris où était les actes
reproductible qui permettent d'aller
dans la bonne direction avec toutes
leurs contreparties pas ce que je vais
vous donner un exemple si on se met à la
sobriété ça veut dire qu'il ya moins de
gens qui travaillent pour produire ce
que vous allez acheter
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
d'eux donc milité pour la sobriété sans
militer pour
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens qui
travaillent dans la filière dont on a
moins besoin c'est avoir fait le job à
moitié donc s'il faut aussi s'intéresser
et là un bond est un bon point de départ
pour les actions personnelles c'est de
regarder ce que vaut son empreinte
carbone à soi donc il ya des
calculateurs ya un calculateur d'avenir
climatique par exemple qui étaient
disponibles car votre carte on est en
train d'en mettre un autre point est à
ce moment vous comprenez où sont les
grandes actions alors ce que vous en
donnez quelques unes
il faut comprendre le poids du numérique
dans ce qu'on consomme aujourd'hui donc
par exemple ce qu'on peut faire d'utile
c'est acheter le moins possible aux
ordinateurs et smartphones les plus
petit possible et moins souvent possible
si vous avez un abonnement à netflix
résilié le netflix occupe à lui seul 20%
de la bande passante internet dans le
monde dont 20 % de la fabrication des
composants de réseaux des antennes des
serveurs d'état etc de tout ça et de
l'entretien de tout ça
à lui tout seul donc c'est il faut il
faut se documenter sur d'où vient le
problème est ensuite voilà dans
l'alimentation c'est de la viande rouge
essentiellement dans les transports si
vous prenez l'avion arrêter de prendre
l'avion ça va être compliqué pour les
erasmus pc si vous y allez pour six mois
à prendre le train le bateau et c'est
donc vous voilà donc il faut il faut
comprendre d'où vient le problème pour
pour avancer alors les lectures sur d'où
vient le problème
elles sont un peu disparate
malheureusement n'y a pas de aujourd'hui
on est un peu obligé d'aller à la pêche
mais mais il faut il faut bien
comprendre derrière comme vous êtes tels
des gens intelligents dans cette
enceinte parce que vous avez sélectionné
pour ça une fois que vous avez compris
d'où vient le problème vous comprendrez
assez naturellement autour de quoi
tourner la solution n'allez pas pêcher
la définition du problème dans la presse
c'est la seul conseil que je vous donne
merci bonjour je voudrais commencer par
un petit renard sur mecha ration ce
piste qui s'intéresserait après au
niveau de la production des gaz de
schiste c'est que après avoir connu une
très belle croissance dans l'année qui
vient elle a commencé sérieusement
atteint un plafond dans les derniers
mois même si
les mises à jour deux derniers mois vont
perdre savoir si on a atteint vraiment
un pic au niveau des gaz de schiste en
tout cas cela peut-être pas trop pour
très longtemps
ma question est pourquoi ils sont
contents aussi peu parlé du solaire
thermodynamique sert pas du
photovoltaïque dans laquelle on a des
panneaux directement mais de la
concentration des rayons sur un liquide
chauffantes et j'en entends jamais
parues dans la presse on n'en entend pas
parler dans la presse pour deux raisons
la première c'est que la france n'est
pas un pays assez un sol et pour que ce
soit quelque chose de très intéressant
chez nous il ya eu une expérience
historique à odeillo 1 il ya longtemps
dans les pyrénées c'est surtout un
procédé qui est intéressant pour des
pays bien un sol et mais vous avez des
projets dont on entend parler dans
d'autres presse dans d'autres pays par
exemple au maroc vous avez un projet de
centrale thermodynamique qui porte le
nom de la princesse marocaine lourds
dont la presse marocaine parle tout à
fait donc ça dépend de quel presse on
parle en france vous n'entendez pas
parlé parce qu'il n'y a pas de projet et
pas de porter d'intérêt faire face au
paradoxe qui est qu'on vit dans un
système compétitif globalisé qui fait
que le premier pays où celui qui décide
de volontairement décroître au bc sont
en pris en son emprise sur le monde sur
les condamner à une chute
est-ce que ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible de faire face à ça est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est possible aussi de
la planification et réaliste parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'exemples qui montrent que
finalement le système mondial est
tellement complexe que même une
planification a très peu souvent les
effets escomptés
est ce que vous
si vous êtes au courant peut-être des
travaux de theodore kaczynski est ce que
vous pensez comme lui que une révolution
qui serait dirigée contre la technologie
pourrait éventuellement lui éviter une
issue catastrophique c'est à dire aller
irrémédiablement dû à ce système
compétitif généralisée vert à une
destruction totale des écosystèmes donc
de la vie humaine
la réponse à la dernière question
directement non vous pouvez pas faire
une révolution contre le fait que les
hommes aiment chercher or le ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler les progrès
technologiques c'est juste le reflet du
fait que les gens aiment chercher il ya
un philosophe je sais plus lequel je
sais pas quand jonas qui a dit tout ce
que nous pouvons nous le ferons et en
fait c'est une manière de dire on est
constamment en train de se demander ce
qu'on pourrait faire d'autre que ce
qu'on fait déjà
on est comme si on est capable et comme
ça donc ça vous empêcherait pas par
contre ce qu'on peut empêcher c'est que
tout développement technologique quel
qu'il soit soit fait d'abord et qu'on se
pose ensuite la question de savoir si
c'était une bonne idée donc c'est à dire
vous pouvez encadrer ce truc est la
seule manière d'encadrer les recherches
c'est par l'éthique et la morale n'y a
pas deux autres manières ce qui veut
dire que les problèmes que je viens
d'évoquer
et c'est un c'est un des fondateurs de
paris dauphine
qui m'a dit ça un jour s'appelle yves
abric landes qui est un norvégien qui a
été un des présidents d'université qui
est un mathématicien norvégien brillant
et qui a dit jamais nous ne résoudrons
le prêt donc ça va rebondir sur votre
première question jamais nous ne
résoudrons le problème du changement
climatique en en faisant un problème
économique
il faut que ça devienne un problème
éthique dit autrement vous ne vous
mettez pas les doigts dans le nez quand
vous êtes invités chez votre belle-mère
pas parce que vous n'êtes pas capables
d'en payer le prix juste parce que ça se
fait pas et du reste vous lui mettez pas
non plus un ramponneau même si elle dit
des trucs qui vous énerve ça juste ça se
fait pas y'a pas un prix pour ça et bien
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique c'est exactement pareil c'est
à dire que tant qu'il ya un prix pour ça
en fait on est à côté de la plaque
il faut que l'on considère que ça ne se
fait pas point vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire c'est mal voilà la définition
du bien et du mal
pensez à les revoir ça sans usage de la
force par exemple oui parce que alors
sans usage de la force s'engage de la
contrainte sûrement bas sans l'usagé de
la force au sens de est ce qu'on n'en
passera par des guerres avant j'espère
que non mais après je n'en sais rien
mais son usage de la contrainte sûrement
pas son usage de friction sûrement pas
après il faut se méfier historiquement
les révolutions quand elles sont bien
faites la situation après et pas
nécessairement mieux que la situation
avant donc donc le
dans des bons 25 ans vous regardez les
exemples britanniques et français sur
l'abandon de la monarchie absolue où les
exemples américains et britanniques sur
l'abandon de l' esclavage ou vous rendez
compte que la politique des petits pas
parfois c'est mieux que la révolution
mais le poids en venir à ce que je
disais on peut pas résoudre ce problème
en en faisant un problème économique
donc ça renvoie à la première question
qui et comment est-ce qu'on peut s'en
sortir dans un monde dit ouvert alors
hein on peut arrêter de dire que c'est
important que le monde soit ouvert et
personnellement je pense que plus
d'ouverture doit avoir une limite car à
un moment où vous dites bien non il ya
une limite
on arrête de voilà jeu il ya des tas de
domaines dans lesquels on considère
qu'il ya des limites
chez vous s'est ouvert un certain nombre
de gens jusqu'au moment où il ya plus de
quoi faire rentrer les gens donc les
limites
il y avait 8 partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui on est sur l'idée stupide
venue de modèle économique stupide qui
lisent plus est ouvert et bien on va se
porter en fait non plus et ouvert et
plus on prend de plus on met de
volatilité dans le système
sauf que temps que l'approvisionnement
économique et énergétique pardon est
croissant là on a un élément de
résilience qui compense cette stabilité
partir du moment où s'est ouvert sans
énergie alors là je peux vous dire
valdinguer sévère donc c'est évident
qu'il faut freiner
aujourd'hui cette affaire là la
construction européenne n'aurait jamais
dû se faire avec une monnaie unique sans
être capable de contrebalancer ce qui
n'est plus possible c'est à dire la
dévaluation avec des transferts sociaux
pour qu'on aurait dû dire aux allemands
on veut bien l'euro mais vous payer pour
les grecs si jamais ils ont un problème
le donc il faut vraiment mettre
aujourd'hui des barrières au libre
échangisme tel qu'il est conçu
maintenant ça n'empêche pas la france de
faire des choses de manière unilatérale
dans un certain nombre de domaines
je vais vous donner deux exemples on
peut très bien aujourd'hui décidée en
france nous autres français qu'on va
s'occuper sérieusement d'autres
organismes
c'est à dire déconcentrés des grandes
villes rénover les bâtiments qui doivent
survivre pour en faire des bâtiments
adaptés à l'énergie et au climat de
demain
j'ai pas besoin de savoir ce que vont
faire les chinois pour ça
et j'ai d'autant moins besoin de savoir
ce que vont faire les chinois pour ça
que de toute façon comme je voulais
montrer tout à l'heure on va
progressivement sur la durée de vie qui
vous restent manquer de pétrole de gaz
et des autres énergies en europe les
aider à dire qu'on pense pas ça donc de
toutes façons on va avoir un problème
pour l'énergie qui alimentent le système
est donc il ya des mesures qu'on a
intérêt à prendre parce qu'il faut que
le système fonctionne avec moins
d'énergie
donc ça voilà un premier exemple et je
me contrefous de savoir ce que fait
trump pour prendre cette décision là
j'ai une deuxième décision que je peux
prendre en france il se trouve qu'un
tiers des camions qui circulent dans ce
pays transporte un truc qui se mange un
tiers donc la dépendance de votre
alimentation au pétrole est absolument
massive
parce que si je supprime les camions
crever de faim je suis totalement
incapable d'alimenter paris tous les
jours avec des trains et les charrettes
à cheval je suis incapable de faire ça
d'accord
donc je supprime les camions crever de
faim littéralement auxilio reste
littéralement
donc vous voyez bien que ça je me
contrefous de savoir ce que fait trump
dans un pays qui va avoir de moins en
moins de pétrole pour me dire qu'il faut
que m'attaque au problème donc vous avez
un certain nombre donc en fait il faut
faire le tri il ya ce pourquoi je ne
suis pas capable d'agir seule dans mon
coin
il ya des sujets qui sont cette nature
mais il ya un milliard de sujets pour
lesquels je me contrefous de savoir ce
que vont faire mes voisins parce que de
toute façon moi j'ai un problème est à
la limite plus vite ils tapent dans les
stocks de pétrole restant est plus vite
moi j'aurai un problème il le dernier
truc que je vais dire c'est que l'homme
est un animal mimétique vous avez j'ai
été élevé par mes parents par mimétisme
c'est à dire qu'une partie des trucs qui
me l'ont dit puis il partit des trucs
ils ont juste fait devant moi et j'ai
fait pareil par exemple j'ai appris à
parler de cette manière corps a été à
l'école pour apprendre à parler j'ai
entendu mes parents parlent et puis j'ai
fait la même chose
et bien je ne crois pas une seule
seconde je ne crois pas une seule
seconde au fait que si les français
commencent à faire des trucs
intelligents et soit dit en passant on
sera pas les seuls mais j'en avais plus
intelligents au monde à faire des trucs
intelligents
je ne crois pas une seule seconde que
les autres ne vont pas en faire pas ne
vont pas faire pareil un moment j'y
crois pas une seconde
donc on a imité les américains pour tout
un peuple qu'on ne voit vraiment pas
pourquoi le reste du monde pourrait pas
imiter les gens qui font des trucs
intelligents
vraiment pas donc je donc l'argument qui
consiste à dire on va était seul à
s'agiter dans notre coin j'y crois pas
une seconde
parce que la nature humaine est une
nature mimétique voir moutonnière dans
un certain nombre de cas de figure c'est
bien pour ça que les effets de mode
bonjour merci pour cette conférence déjà
vous avez dit puis il faut choisir entre
co2 et pib ça veut quand même dire qu'il
n'ya pas d'autre alternative que
l'énergie fossile en gros est-ce que
vous pourrez pas trouver dans les
pâturages ou tard la question pour vous
alors si vous choisissez le pib à court
terme oui je vous pose la question
puisse éveiller tous est ce que on peut
pas trouver une alternative dont le
nucléaire pas forcément dans la fission
b dans la fusion nucléaire
alors la réponse est non malheureusement
en fait il ya une alternative dans la
fiction n'y a pas d'alternative dans la
fusion je vais vous dire pourquoi la
fusion donc vous avez deux manières
d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire et c'est
lié au fait que l'énergie de liaison
entre les nucléons dans un noyau passe
par un maximum aux alentours du noyau du
fer donc quand vous avez des atomes qui
sont plus petits que le faire en les
regroupant vous arrivez à récupérer de
l'énergie
quand vous avez des noyaux qui sont plus
gros que le faire ce qui est le cas de
l'uranium en les cassant vous arrivez à
récupérer l'énergie d'un deuxième cas
s'appelle la fission dans le premier cas
ça fait de la fusion dans la fusion est
une énergie qu'on connaît très bien
parce que c'est avec ça que soleil
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que la
première génération des toiles à part
alchimie fait tous les éléments du
tableau de mendeleïev quand ils ont tous
été faits à partir de noyaux d'hydrogène
sert de protons dans la première
génération d'étoilés dans une étoile ça
marche très bien
malheureusement pour reproduire ces
conditions là sur terre c'est compliqué
parce que le plasma dans une étoile la
matière est dans un état particulier
dans une étoile ou les électrons et les
noyaux ne sont plus associés
ils se baladent chacun de leur côté et
ça s'appelle un plasma et pour avoir un
plasma vous devez porter la matière à
quelques millions de degrés comme dans
les indestructibles à des millions eh
bien vous ne savez pas mettre ça dans
une boîte à chaussures simple donc ça
veut dire que vous devez faire du
confinement magnétique enfin bref c'est
un humain un truc très compliqué et pour
chauffer votre plasma à quelques
millions de degrés vous devez utiliser
de l'énergie vais commencer par chauffer
et donc le grand défi de la fusion c'est
d'arriver à récupérer avec la fusion
plus
nrj vous n'en avez utilisé pour chauffer
le plasma alors dans les tokamaks c'est
à dire les usines qui ont enfin les et
trucs qu'on utilise aujourd'hui on sait
faire des réactions de fusion qui dure
moins longtemps qu'il n'en faut pour
récupérer l'énergie de chauffe du plasma
dans iter le défi c'est de faire plus
long temps qu'il n'en faut pour
récupérer l'énergie de chauffe du plasma
mais quand même pas des heures et des
heures
or une centrale électrique aujourd'hui
on doit être capable de fonctionner 5000
heures sans s'arrêter vous dit pas je
vais faire un pitch de deux minutes dans
lequel les gens vont avoir de
l'électricité
1 je m'arrête trois heures pour refaire
des conditions de l'expérience puis je
refais un pitch de deux minutes et c'est
donc iter qui va faire juste un peu plus
va avoir son premier placement en 2025
après faut le faire fonctionner dix ans
pour avoir un retour d'expérience 2035
ensuite faut se gratter la tête pendant
cinq ans pour savoir ce qu'on fait
derrière 2040
ensuite en mai en construction la
génération d'après qui sera peut-être
capable de fonctionner quelques milliers
d'heures s'est terminée en 2055 ou 2060
puis on le fait fonctionner dix ans de
1070 donc avec un peu de chance en 2085
vous serez mort eh bien si
n'en déplaise à laurent alexandre vous
serez mort eh bien nous aurons peut-être
la tête de série de quelque chose qui
pourrait nous aider à régler un problème
c'est la règle de trois que j'ai passé
dans la démonstration qu'il faut avoir
réglé dans les trente cinq ans qui
viennent c'est à dire que pour tenir les
deux degrés de l'accord de paris il faut
que les émissions planétaires arrive à
zéro d'ici 2060 0 pas la moitié
zéro plus un gramme de co2 émis dans
l'atmosphère plus une bagnole à essence
plus une fabrication de batteries soit
dit en passant parce que c'est de la
métallurgie qui émet du co2 plus rien
zéro d'accord
donc on est totalement hors course avec
la fusion ce qui est une autre manière
de dire que budget d'iter est totalement
inutile pour le problème dont je vous
parle par contre la fission aujourd'hui
on là ça marche
et quand vous regardez alors j'ai pas le
temps de vous faire le détail
aujourd'hui mais j'ai quelques lectures
sur mon site
il ya une page sur mon site qui
s'appelle
si on y voit ribbon discussion autour de
quelques inconvénients de quelques idées
reçues sur nucléaire civil allez voir ça
vous allez voir que le problème
nucléaire en france est avant tout après
médiatique
c'est à dire que si on vous parlait dans
la presse de ce qui pose problème faut
vous parler tous les jours du tabac de
l'alcool des suicides et des accidents
domestiques qui arrive bien avant les
accidents de la route
je signale que il ya vingt mille
personnes par an qui meurent chez dell
de chute de suffocation de noyade et
c'est alors que dès qu'il ya un wc
bouché dans une centrale nucléaire vous
entendez parler dans la presse
donc vous avez un une focalisation sur
ce truc là en france qui n'est pas du
tout représentatif de ces inconvénients
réels donc moi je fais partie des gens
qui pensent que le nucléaire est un
amortisseur de la décroissance comme ça
je le présente
il ya un amortisseur des emmerdements
pour des inconvénients associés à la
filière qui n'ont qu'ils sont mineurs
au regard de totalement négligeable au
regard de vous donner juste deux
exemples le plus vieux site de stockage
de déchets nucléaires au monde il a 2
milliards d'années il est apparu
naturellement dans un réacteur qui s'est
formée naturellement à au clos au gabon
or donc il ya des déchets en libre
circulation dans la nature depuis des
milliards d'années est ce que ça vous a
empêché de vivre non deuxième truc qu'il
faut savoir
en france on fait quelques toutes les
déchets nucléaires de 40 ans
d'exploitation des centrales françaises
tiennent dans cet amphi danse est un
film nous répandons en france chaque
année dans la nature 100 mille tonnes de
phytosanitaires qui sont aussi dangereux
en termes de toxicité que les déchets
nucléaires dont nous faisons quelques
centaines de tonnes par an qu'on met
dans une boîte en phytosanitaires que 50
à 100 mille tonnes par an dispersés dans
la nature
deux exemples je vous assure que enfin
ma conviction alors à fluide et agréable
à forger moi je vais travailler dans
cette filière là mais et je me suis
intéressé aux changements climatiques
bien avant de m'intéresser à l'énergie
mais c'est des inconvénients qu'ils sont
mineurs donc c'est une manière de dire
que de développer la filière aussi vite
que possible
fait partie des amortisseurs du grand
saut dans le vide qu'on est en train
d'entamer c'est ça mon
le nucléaire qui demande à être
développé pour que l'on puisse en faire
quelque chose de pas ridicule sur plus
de 50 ans parce que la filière actuelle
on est plutôt de malheureusement limité
par l'uranium 235 donc ça sera jamais
majeur c'est la génération d'après ce
qu'on appelle la génération 4 qui
exploite soit l'uranium 238 folle
thorium et le budget dit r on aurait été
beaucoup mieux inspiré en france et plus
exactement en europe de le mettre sur un
programme fasttrack sur la génération 4
qui n'évitera pas la sobriété qui
n'hésitera pas à la récession qui
n'évitera pas toutes les économies
d'énergie etc mais qui contribuera à
alléger
de manière plus ou moins importante
l'effort qu'on devra faire sur les
autres plans bonjour la playlist alexis
et donc je me demandais la chose
suivante
donc on va parler j'aimerais aborder
plus tôt dans canal donc l'aspect du
contrôle de foule avec donc à vous
parliez donc pour faire le lien avec la
première question qui était posée par
l'apport de mes camarades donc comme
quoi il y aurait à kohler à coup sûr des
mois des mouvements de foule et de
nombreux problèmes sociaux comment
comment on peut déjà dedans quand on l'a
déjà que donc quand on voit qu'il ya une
relative hausse du prix du carburant on
se retrouve avec une manifestation de
grande ampleur que le gouvernement a du
mal à gérer
alors vous qui avez côtoyé donc les
hommes politiques actuels
est-ce que vous sauriez si d'une part
ils ont une des deux collègues de
comment faire pour gérer ses moyens ses
mouvements de foule et douala et d'autre
part c'est donc étant donné que vous
avez dû être témoin de la tête de
l'évolution est d'arriver d'être des
différentes générations d'hommes
paulette d'hommes politiques depuis
quelques années si vous placez vous
pensez qu'ils noueraient des solutions
parce que tu as donné que des gens en
france après la révolution française
abouti sur donc 3 qui se fait
guillotiner est-ce que pas de finir
pareil pour les responsables politiques
qui seront pouvoir à ce moment là que
c'est probablement d'être ça de notre
génération
merci beaucoup je ne suis pas
complètement sûr que parmi tous les
malheurs qui peuvent arriver à macron la
guillotine fasse partie des plus
probables
[Musique]
il y à une somme de problèmes qui permet
d'aller vers un dialogue apaisé avec des
gens qu'on a rappelé les gilets jaunes
dans ce que dans cette affaire l'a
d'abord il ya quand même une incapacité
très forte de la classe politique à
faire la pédagogie du problème c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui ils sont pas
capables d'en faire la pédagogie est en
fait l'une des raisons essentielles
c'est que déjà ils n'en savent rien
parce que ce que je vous ai raconté une
partie significative si vous avez bien
écouter ne se trouve pas dans le journal
ça peut dire qu'elle n'existe pas je ne
saviez pas ça y est j'ai mis très
longtemps à comprendre que si je
comprenais rien à un article du monde
c'est pas moi qui étais content c'était
que le journaliste du monde n'avait rien
compris
parce que pendant très longtemps je me
suis dit c'est quand même c'est le
journal de référence j'ai vu mon père
lire ça pendant mon père physicien c'est
à dire ça pendant toute ma jeunesse
donc si je comprends pas ce qui est
écrit dans l'article c'est je dois
vraiment être con et puis j'arrive pas à
comprendre
on m'a sélectionné pour entrer dans une
des meilleures écoles de france et je
n'arrive pas à comprendre ce qu'il écrit
dans l'article
mais j'ai un problème enfin j'ai du
héros créé par hasard les ennemis très
longtemps très très longtemps et ça va
demander quelque part une espèce de
prétention absolument insupportable de
me dire non c'est juste que make a rien
compris
juste ça ou qu'il est totalement orienté
biaisé machin etc
donc il ya une incapacité à faire la
pédagogie du problème auprès de la
population parce que les médias ne font
pas correctement leur job parce que
l'éducation nationale fait pas
correctement 100 g soit dit en passant
est parce que dans les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur je suis ravi
qu'on me donnait l'occasion de
m'exprimer devant vous il reste on a
fait un gros travail aux chiffres
project pour faire l'inventaire de ce
qui existe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 90% de ceux qui vous ont
précédés dans cet établissement et
d'autres sortes de l'enseignement
supérieur sans avoir jamais eu le
moindre cours obligatoires sur ce genre
de sujets d'accords donc ils sortent de
l'enseignement supérieur sans avoir bien
compris comment se présentait le
problème à traiter
je parle pas de savoir s'il faut avoir
finement c'est quoi la finance climat
reprend goût à ce stade c'est je
comprends bien pour les retraités
donc ils sont pas capables de faire la
pédagogie du problème or quand vous
n'êtes pas capable de faire la pédagogie
du problème tout effort est
insupportable c'est à dire que si
approche vous envoie au piquet on vous
écrit sans vous expliquer pourquoi je
pense pas que vous aviez trouvé que
c'est juste donc là on dit au gilet
jaune
on va vous augmentez prix du carburant
on vous dit pas le pourquoi du comment
vous dit pas c'est pour maintenir le
pays en paix on vous dit pas c'est parce
que toute façon il ya moins
on vous dit pas comment on va alléger
votre peine et on vous dit rien on est
juste on va augmenter c'est évident que
ça allait mal se passer
je les écris un certain nombre de fois
j'ai écrit en 2011 un papier dans les
échos qui s'appelait marine le pen enfin
du carbone voulez lire elle est encore
sur mon site donc c'est évident enfin
évident je serre les matchs se passer si
on fait la pédagogie du problème
on peut très bien traité le problème et
je vais vous donner deux exemples mais
gilet jaune sont souvent des ruraux les
ruraux ce show se chauffent souvent au
fioul
il se trouve que dans notre pays on a
décidé de mettre 25 milliards d'euros
sur l'éolien offshore
c'est d euros qui vont être payés par
vos impôts enfin pour vous vous ne payez
pas beaucoup mais ceux de vos parents
les biens et ceux des gilets jaunes soit
dit en passant parce que ça va être payé
par des taxes sur le carburant donc le
compte d'affectation spéciale de la
transition énergétique est aujourd'hui
essentiellement financé par des taxes
sur les carburants et ça sert
essentiellement à financer du pv
l'éolien qui ne résolvent en rien les
problèmes de transport donc on va faire
de l'éolien offshore pour 25 milliards
c'était aux liens offshore ne va
économiser aucun gramme de co2 dans
notre pays puisque l'électricité est
essentiellement décarbonée ça ne va pas
créer d'emplois en macro économiquement
parce que ça va plutôt avoir tendance à
augmenter les importations parce qu'il
faut importer plus de composants pour
faire les éoliennes qu'on importe
d'uranium pour faire d'électricité
nucléaire
ça va créer des problèmes locaux à n'en
plus pouvoir
et j'ai dit à edouard philippe le jour
de l'installation du haut conseil
moi si j'étais toi c'est 25 milliards je
met une croix donc il ya quelques anti
nucléaires qui vont gueuler dans le
monde pendant quinze jours très bien
grand bien leur fasse
et avec ses 25 milliards 24 parce que
sinon la division ton pas juste je donne
6000 euros de prime à chaque ménage
français chauffées au fioul qui soit dit
en passant sont essentiellement les
gilet jaune pour remplacer sa chaudière
à fuel par une pompe à chaleur 6000
euros par ménage
je peux vous assurer que si vous faites
ça il compare alors aujourd'hui ça coûte
10 villes si vous faites ça et que vous
faites intervenir le différentiel de
prix entre le fioul et l'électricité il
gagne en argent vous n'avez plus qu'une
solution bancaire à mettre entre les
deux easy gagne pourquoi est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait parce que la pédagogie du
problème n'a pas été fait parce que eux
mêmes ne comprennent pas le problème à
traiter parce que eux-mêmes pense que
d'empêcher les antinucléaires de gueuler
dans le monde c'est plus important que
de résoudre en pratique un problème
qu'on
avec une fraction de la population qui
commence à être d éjecter du pétrole
voilà c'est juste ça il y avait une
solution je vais vous la donner du
pognon il y en a plein à preuve il ya 25
milliards sauf qu'on va pas les mettre
au bon endroit
donc on a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
j'insiste de je tape à côté de la plaque
parce que la plaque n'est pas comprise
c'est pour ça que j'ai tant insisté j'ai
pas parlé de solutions aujourd'hui
j'étends insisté sur la définition du
problème parce que tant que cette
dernière n'est pas bien comprise toute
solution c'est taper au hasard et vous
êtes suffisamment vieux maintenant pour
savoir que quand vous taper au hasard
pour résoudre un problème la probabilité
pour vous arriviez à le résoudre a quand
même pas très élevé dernier point je
pense que c'est idiot de prendre les
gens pour des cons donc je suis
fortement convaincus du fait que de
faire de la pédagogie du problème même
si ça conduit à dire aux gens vous allez
en baver c'est beaucoup plus payant que
de les prendre pour des andouilles
et je vais vous donner une expérience
historique il faut que j'ai racontée
exactement le même genre de discours là
ça va chier des bulles carré devant une
réunion des syndicats de la cfdt dans
une branche
je leur ai expliqué que pouvoir d'achat
les b c etc
je me suis dit on sortira grand coup de
pied dans le derrière pas du tout ça a
été une des audiences les plus
intéressés à discuter que j'ai jamais
trouvé
donc je suis fermement convaincu du fait
que c'est une erreur politique
fondamentale de prendre les gens pour
des andouilles bonjour pourquoi cet
attachement à la civilisation alors que
en plus d'être un système marqué par la
culture du conte du contrôle qui s'ils
continuent à se développer ne peut que
déboucher sur une impasse qui nous
transformera en esclaves des robots et
est en plus et qui est marquée par une
folie d'aider des grandeurs différentes
appelées l'hubris pourquoi cet
attachement à la civilisation alors
qu'il s'agit en plus d'un mode de vie
qui n'est absolument pas naturel
puisqu'il représente moins de 95 pour
moins de 5% de l'histoire de l'humanité
et que alors que quand nous ne faisons
rien nous nous en mer dont nous sommes
sujets à l'anxiété à l' angoisse en
raison des pressions exercées sur nous
par la situation alors que souvent alors
que plupart des gens qui est sondhi up
qui sont dits de peuples primitifs sont
très contents quand ils n'ont pas de
travail à faire de rester assis pendant
des heures à ne rien faire parce que
contrairement à nous ils sont en paix
avec eux mêmes et avec le monde
alors
[Applaudissements]
eh bien je n'ai pas la réponse dix
autres avant pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
comme on est c'est une bonne question
j'aimerais bien avant la réponse alors
je vais pourquoi est-ce qu'on se met à
faire des choses qui avec le recul du
temps paraissent être des conneries
parce que de temps en temps on se trompe
on est tous ainsi fait je sais pas si
vous vous avez jamais fait d'erreur dans
votre vie moi j'en ai fait donc de temps
en temps on se trompe
et alors de temps en temps on peut se
tromper collectivement malheureusement
il ya plein d'exemples historiques ou de
temps en temps on se trompe
collectivement par ailleurs il ya des
situations qui sont peu réversible faust
aurait très bien pu ne pas vendre son
âme au diable
il sera démerder pour tomber amoureux de
quelqu'un de moins bien marguerite je
croise était bon il aurait été un peu
moins heureusement faire la fin ils
avaient quand même pas besoin de vendre
son âme au diable
nous on est un peu dans un pacte
faustien dans cette histoire on a un peu
vendu notre âme au diable c'est à dire
on se promet un lendemain qui risque
d'être un peu rock'n'roll contre le fait
qu'effectivement on est vécu une
parenthèse qui a été une parenthèse
courte dans l'histoire des hommes
selon les scientifiques l'homme c'est un
bilan sans bilan et c'est là on a vécu
deux siècles ça va encore durer dix
vingt trente ans je sais pas pas de
nouveau siècle ça c'est sûr de quelque
chose qui est quelque part une forme de
corne d'abondance qui semble n'avoir
aucun inconvénient
on a plus de doute et on a l'impression
qu'il a pas d'inconvénient les
inconvénients commencent à arriver
alors pourquoi ce qu'on a fait ça je
pense qu'une des raisons et les
biologique tout bêtement
c'est à dire qu'avant d'être des animaux
qui pensons réfléchir on est des animaux
points donc on fait confiance à nos sens
et nos sens ils sont tous court termiste
toucher l'ouïe la vue l'odorat tous
assez court termiste c'est la raison par
lequel pour laquelle par exemple on a
beaucoup de mal à faire comprendre que
c'est qu'une moyenne à quelqu'un dire
quand vous lui parlez de la température
moyenne les gens comprennent pas parce
que la température que vous êtes
capables de sentir avec votre toucher
c'est la température qui fait dans cette
pièce aujourd'hui température moyenne
vous la sentez temps donc on fait
confiance à nos sens et nos sens ils
nous ont structuré à nous comporter en
mode essai erreur c'est à dire que toute
l'histoire des animaux et c'est comme ça
qu'on fait l'éducation c'est de faire
des erreurs
l'essentiel du temps réversible quand
elles sont pas en meurent voilà nos
douze ans entendre l'apprentissage
collectif d'une population d'animaux
y compris chez les hommes mais on est en
mode et ses erreurs
là on est face à des problèmes globaux
qui ne se contente pas d'un mode essai
erreur donc il faut qu'on arrive à
s'extraire de notre biologie pour
arriver à répondre positivement à la
question que vous posez et c'est
vachement dur de s'extraire de sa
biologie
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça c'est une
façon de dire pourquoi c'est rien ça
s'est passé comme ça et puis parce qu'on
est des animaux moi j'ai une deuxième
question qui me paraît plus intéressant
qui est une fois qu'on sait ce conseil
comme disait l'autre
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'utile pour
que ça se passe un peu mieux plutôt
qu'un peu plus mal voilà parce que
admettons qu'on soit dans la merde comme
vous venez de le dire simplement et bien
qu est-ce qu on peut ensuite qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour rester en plus un
peu simpliste parce que cette merde à
plein de bons côtés je sais pas si vous
êtes très malheureuse de devoir étudié à
sciences po plutôt que devoir aller
ramasser les patates mais une fois qu'on
voulait sa réponse une fois que on a
cette réponse la question encore une
fois c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'utile
parce que dans la décision est la
décision publique pour en revenir à ce
qui vous concernera pour partie au fonds
opposés le monde merveilleux au monde
merdique ça n'a pas une grande valeur
opérationnelle la seule valeur
opérationnelle s'est opposée entre elles
les alternatives qui sont à ma main à un
instant donné
d'accord ça ça une valeur opérationnelle
les alternatives vous pouvez les
concevoir en fonction d'un monde idéal
vers lequel vous avez envie d'aller à
supposer qu'on puisse donc dans un
premier temps je reviens des trucs très
simple on comprend là où on est dans un
deuxième temps on voit où sont les voies
de sortie possible jusque là plusieurs
toutes sont imparfaites c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure on entre et vous
n'aurez que des problèmes mal posée et
des solutions multiples ça c'est un
exemple typique et une fois que
collectivement on s'est mis d'accord sur
ce qui nous paraissait moins idiot à ce
moment on met en oeuvre les alternatives
qui correspondent à cette affaire là et
ses alternatives sont toujours lente
parce que malheureusement une fois qu'on
est quelques milliards sur terre et 60
millions en france
même dans un système dictatorial parce
que vous avez des dictatures dans le
monde
oui que ça bouge pas si vide que ça
c'est des systèmes sont blancs et on
essaye d'avancer avec un peu de
constance parce qu on espère que la
définition qu'on a eu du problème est la
définition qu'on a de la solution sont
pas à changer tous les 4 matins parce
qu'on a bien compris d'entrée de jeu
et donc on n'a pas changé d'avis tout le
temps aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est
pas exactement le cas
vous voyez qu'on est dedans je change
d'avis et puis on n'a pas une idée
claire de problèmes à traiter et d'où
ils situent par rapport aux autres ce
qui est absolument fondamentale et ça
rapproche de la question qui a été posée
tout à l'heure sur est ce qu'on peut
trouver d'autres motifs d'espoir que le
pib c'est exactement à une question à
vous poser quelque part où est le sens
qui peut nous faire oublier l'effort
alors je reviens à mon truc trivial du
camping dans la montagne mois à l'été je
fais de la montagne je transpire un
grand coup c'est beaucoup moins
confortable que d'être assis dans mon
canapé
mais je suis très content parce que je
trouve un sens à ce que je fais qui me
fait oublier le fait que je vais
transpirer comme ceux ci que cela est
bien c'est donc le mot essentiel pour
moi donc vous l'avez dit en filigrane
dans votre intervention c'est d'arriver
à faire revenir du sens dans ce qu'on
fait est là où je suis absolument
certain de mon cou
c'est qu'il n'a pas de sens a augmenté
les résultats trimestriels en tant que
tel ça n'a pas de sens pour ça qu'ils
voient que les grands trucs qui ont du
sens dans la vie d'un homme ou d'une
femme
c'est tombé amoureux voir grandir ses
enfants de manière harmonieuse avoir
confiance dans le lendemain etc
c'est pas que des indicateurs monétaires
donc il ya plein de trucs qui sont
indispensables et aujourd'hui je
considère donc là je vais être un peu
paquin aussi avec quelques anciens de
cette maison que les politiques sont
devenus par est ce parce que ils ne font
pas l'effort de concevoir des programmes
qui sont résistants aux contraintes et
qui porte du sens malgré les contraintes
dont on parle de réformes des réformes
et donc certainement elle est probable
que les chasseurs cueilleurs sont plus
heureux que nous parce qu'ils font
exactement ce que vous avez il exécute
exactement ce que vous avez décrit dans
votre compte ping à la montagne le
processus de pouvoir c'est à dire le
processus par lequel il apprend à
assurer sa survie par ce même et il est
probable jeu collectif les chasseurs
cueilleurs son collectif il ya du
pouvoir mais effectivement ils ont une
vision plus fataliste du monde ce qui
fait qu'il ya une partie des
inconvénients qu'ils acceptent beaucoup
mieux je pas sûr qu'ils aient la même
espérance de vie que les français et le
voilà donc yaya et c'est beaucoup plus
facile de ne pas avoir envie d'un truc
que vous ignorez que de renoncer à
quelque chose que vous avez connu c'est
beaucoup plus facile on a
merci oui il faut que je sois eux
c'était une dernière question
la question est celle de la limite
physique du temps alors vos amis louer
les journalistes nous communique deux
fois par jour lundi ce du cac 40
oui avez-vous existe-t-il un indice qui
pourrait justement sensibiliser de
manière quotidienne les gens au
réchauffement climatique ou au progrès
qu'on pourrait faire non diminué ces
noms vous n'avez pas quelque chose qui
peut se calculer
non vous n'avez pas d'indicateur
quotidien pertinent sur un problème qui
est long d'accord donc la réponse est
non et la réponse c'est ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure faut supprimer la
cotation en continu des entreprises
comme ça vous supprimerez les deux
minutes de temps d'antenne sur france
info payer avec les impôts à raconter
des conneries et un moyen de
sensibiliser au quotidien alors en
parler et en parler et en parler quand
je veux dire je le redis tant que la
pédagogie du problème et pas fait ça et
mon père qui était enseignant dizaine
enseignement est un nom rabâchage
d'enseignement et donc en parler et on
parlait en parler pourquoi l'économie
est importante parce que vous entendez
parler que de ça quand il est question
d'indicateurs quantifier on en entend
parler en parler on va en parler donc à
des trucs utiles que vous pouvez faire
s'est engueulé un journaliste à chaque
fois qu'il en parle pas assez ou qu'ils
en parlent de travers je vous assure
qu'à du boulot merci
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
non c'était un très bon moment
et je vais finir des talons donc je vais
finir quand même en vous disant ce que
je dis à mes élèves quand je termine mon
cours la bonne chance pour l'avenir
[Applaudissements]